he made me think that you know
everything was going to be reversed and
okay and anybody that
money was borrowed from they would get
it back you know maybe tenfold and so it
was this weird situation of
having like one foot in his reality
and
potentially believing the things he was
saying or
even over time
wanting to believe them more and more
because the alternative was so
the alternative was worse the
alternative was like
was increasingly a bigger and bigger
nightmare
the following is a conversation with
sarma melangalis
a chef and restaurateur who was the
subject of the netflix documentary bad
vegan
fame fraud and fugitives that documents
the rise and fall of her vegan raw food
restaurants in new york city that ended
in what she called a road trip from hell
being arrested in tennessee her pleading
guilty for stealing over 2 million
dollars and serving 4 months at rikers
island jail
sarma disputes the veracity of the
documentary and its conclusions saying
that she was misrepresented
so i wanted to talk to her to get the
full story and to seek understanding of
who she is as a human being the good
and the bad
this is the lex freeman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's sama mangalas
you've said that you did a lot of
reading when you were growing up and you
mentioned fear and loathing in las vegas
by hunter s thompson
so from the reading you've done in those
early days
how did you see the world
was it to you a beautiful place or a
cruel place
i don't think i thought about the world
you're focused on family just basic
day-to-day life i think i was focused on
day to day i had an awareness of not
fitting in but i think back then it felt
like something was wrong versus
some people are just that way
and speaking of books i read a book
called um
party of one by a woman named annelie
rufus that somebody gave me and
suggested i read and that helped a lot
that was that was one book that made me
feel like
it made me understand things from the
past that i hadn't understood before
specifically kind of feeling out of
place even among my family which is
where you're not supposed to feel out of
place
yeah i'm not sure where i saw it but i
think you mentioned that you're a bit of
a loner and i also think
i saw somewhere pictures of you with the
with green hair
in high school and a wild haircut what's
that about is that was that real am i
just imagining no you're not imagining
it it's strange because
i was kind of a a loner
so it'd be strange to do something that
calls so much attention to yourself
because back then i mean i grew up in a
suburb of boston um in newton
and
anybody that was there around that time
probably if you said you know that girl
with green hair or blue hair was blue
most of the time they would remember
like seeing me walking down the street
because it stood out like crazy
especially back then now it wouldn't
stand out so much but back then it
really stood out
so
i was trying to think about why
i did that when
i i was kind of a kind of shy and
on the one hand wouldn't want to bring
attention to myself but i did something
that did
and it wasn't
my family to their credit
they were fine with it so it wasn't a
rebellion against them or anything like
that they were fine with it i don't
think they loved it but yeah dad was a
physicist at mit yes so
uh so he was he was cool here with your
green hair when you're a rebellion
that's just the way of life he was fine
with the green hair but i think in some
ways maybe they had to be fine with it
because i didn't cause problems
otherwise and
i got good grades in school
i
was a very low maintenance child i think
even with a green hair
uh so hunter s thompson uh wrote a lot
of good stuff uh
he has a lot of just brilliant quotes a
lot of brilliant lines um so
one of the ones i love is life should
not be a journey to the grave with the
intention of arriving safely in a pretty
and well-preserved body but rather just
skidding broadside in a cloud of smoke
thoroughly used up totally worn out
and loudly proclaiming
wow what a ride
what do you think about that is that
good life advice
from hunter s thompson
i think so
he i think he followed it right
somewhere um i heard recently what he
consumed in a day
yeah and it was
kind of astonishing
it's funny i when i was in college there
were always really interesting people
coming through speakers and whatnot and
i tended to not go to events and whatnot
but in the four years i was there the i
mean really interesting people came
through and gave talks you know i don't
know just
a lot of famous people and
um but then one day hunter s thompson
came to speak and i was the only one i
attended oh wow so the only
interesting person who came to speak on
the campus that i attended was hunter s
thompson and he had a
you know he had a glass of whatever it
was whiskey
and i don't remember a whole lot about
it but it was it was entertaining
and yeah i mean later in his life he
started making less and less sense but
he was still somehow
like embodying the the crazy that he
represented throughout his life the
boldness the fearlessness the wildness
all that kind of stuff and we'll talk
about johnny depp a little bit too funny
enough there's like a echo
obviously he
johnny depp played him
or he started unloading and they hung
out together and it just seemed to
somehow
like the universe rhymes in these two
individuals
they're both mad men and in different
kind of ways so you also told me that
leon the professional is one of your
favorite films
it's also the reason you named your dog
leon so
uh what do you find beautiful and
powerful about this film
i've watched it a bunch of times but
it's been a while since i've watched it
so for people who haven't watched it it
there's a guy named leon played by jon
renau
there's a
um a young girl
i don't know 13 14.
matilda played by natalie portman
and she's abused she has a really hard
life
her parents are spoiler alert
uh murdered
and then she finds protection under this
um
fella
uh
leon who's also happens to be a
professional assassin
and he is also kind of a forest gump
type character like he's a really simple
human uh he almost he seems to be like
the immature one or like rather the one
who's young and she seems to have a
wisdom far beyond her age
because of the hard life she had to live
through and then and they're here
huddling together
from the the cruelty of the world um
in and finding connection
yeah i think it's one of those films
where there's so many interesting things
about it but
you know i'm sure one of them is just
the contradiction of him being
a caring person and reluctant to get
attached to her you know he tries to i
think he knows he's he's very reluctant
to get attached to her in the beginning
um
and
so you see all of his humanity but yet
he's also an assassin that kills people
so
um
that's interesting and i think
probably a psychoanalyst would have a
field day with why i like that movie so
much um and i haven't neces i haven't
gone there myself but
there's something i think about she
even in the brief part
that depicts her in the beginning
it seems clear that she's sort of out of
place in her family
um
and
um and then yeah there's all kinds of
interesting things about their
relationship along the way
what i like about that movie and i had
to think about it recently because i've
read stuff about it
that bothered me
or it bothered me the fact that i
haven't really thought about it before
for people haven't watched the movie so
here's a young underage girl who kind of
comes onto him
first of all i think she actually just
doesn't
know what
like familial love is
so this is the only way she knows how to
express love that's one
and two is
you know a lot of bad people in this
world would take advantage of that
right
and the fact that
um
she finally met a human being who
doesn't
and is just there to protect her
that's a real sort of um
i don't know a powerful statement of
what it means to be sort of like a
father figure i suppose a protector
so that
that to me i i i love the idea of being
the sort of the the protector
that there's something
like uh something worthwhile in this
world to protect
amidst all the cruelty that's all around
so that's that's a beautiful kind of
you're basically saving
this young humans
or you're repairing this young human's
path
to love to real love
in life because that idea of love was
destroyed for her just family everything
is is everything is uh
sort of uh everything around is broken
and he's kind of repairing it by
re-establishing what that kind of love
can be i don't know
and the plant
that's spreading they save the plant
also
well there's also just a simple the
simplicity of the film just from a
cinematic perspective is beautiful the
music
the way it looks the minimalism even the
violence was beautiful
yeah violence it was over the top
and also the the bad guy the bad cop
played by um
gary oldman
yeah he was amazing yeah i think he was
listening to beethoven or something like
that and you're taking some sort of
pills and drugs and some kind and
uh so there was a kind of like uh like
like it's part of the orchestra like the
violence was part
of the
of some kind of
musical creation
yeah it's interesting because i i turn
away from
violence or films usually that have
violence or tv or anything that has that
sort of
um
element to it except in certain
cases where
um
where the violence is beautiful
yeah
yeah or um
did you see the movie true romance
uh yes that's my second favorite movie
okay that's probably my favorite movie
yeah oh well interesting that's my
second favorite movie um that's that's a
more uh simple kind of love but also
with the violence that is beautiful yeah
as you could say yeah and my um
my favorite scene is the one with
patricia arquette and james gandolfini
oh yeah was she there's a shotgun
involved yeah yeah
and then it actually makes me cry every
time i see it
for some reason
[Laughter]
so for people who haven't seen the film
i think
i think he's actually he think he's
hitting her
or
um like there's blood and violence and
so on because he's resisting being
murdered
yeah there's a lot of violence and then
you know he throws her into the glass
um the shower yeah
thing and she's all cut up and beat up
and only and she laughs yeah there's
just so much passion in it you know
she's she knows she's gonna or
in that moment she
knows or thinks she knows that she's
gonna die anyway yeah because she she
knows he's gonna kill her yeah so she
kind of gives it her
gives it all she has and um
but she also just says guts she's not
afraid
yeah
well and also she's um
you know she loves clarence
yeah the love comes through through that
violence yeah yeah just like uh clarence
her fella
in that film
uh has the same kind of thing when he
visits well it was gary oldman again it
was gary oldman again that's right the
pimp looking very drexel drexel yeah
yeah and he's also fearless in that
interaction saying she's not mine
it's interesting that movie is so
romantic
and that a happy ending spoiler alert in
a way that's what i like about it too
because i i feel like some movies should
come with
i don't want to watch a movie if it's
going to be devastating usually unless
it's worthwhile in some other way but
i'm kind of sensitive and i don't want
um i don't like movies that have a
terrible ending you know i mean
there's a book i read because it got so
many good reviews and the very last
scene the woman steps in front of a
train and it was like
um so i'm partial to movies with happy
endings leon ends
with loss
beyond the movie right but it's still
inspiring a love persists in some kind
of form yeah persists and the plant
and the plant
um okay sure sure
true romance does have one of the i mean
it's probably unhealthy and the whole
scene is just amazing you're so cool was
she
is that one knowing where she just kind
of
looks at clarence and her son and child
or whatever and
she's saying you're so cool you're so
cool
yeah
that's that's love
i just that movie has so much in it
because it's
you know it's funny and there's so many
so many good actors in that film and
brad pitt uh plays in that film a
pivotal role of pothead on couch yeah
they're just they're all so good and
funny and michael rappaport yeah and um
and even val kilmer people don't realize
he's in the movie because he doesn't
look like himself
um wait what what is val val kilmer's in
the very end it's
um you know when he's there's like the
elvis sitting there
talking to him in the end yeah that's
val kilmer
yeah you don't notice it unless you
yeah somehow either are very perceptive
or noticed in the credits yeah and uh
quentin tarantino wrote the film i think
yes which is interesting
uh directed by tony scott and the music
is uh beautiful too and christopher
walken and um
um
dennis
hopper dennis hopper dennis hopper plays
clarence's
dad uh dad and they have this
very racist sounding scene but
the big
uh
important aspect of that scene is it's a
father
willing to die
to protect the sun i mean it's so much
so much beautiful violence there is
there is i love that phil so much uh and
she's a prostitute or not really
part-time short time no it was her first
time first time yeah
okay and he saved her
and uh
hmm
my third favorite film has no violence
whatsoever what's your third um a room
with a view
i feel like you'd like it it's um
um
i forget the author it's a book and i i
read the book much later um but it's um
helena bonham carter
and um
uh daniel day-lewis
is in it and julian sands
daniel day-lewis is a fascinating
character
he's amazing in this film because he
plays
he's very funny he sort of plays a he's
a comical character which is unlike
most of what he does i think i don't
watch a ton of movies so
um but
yeah he played his his role is funny
well that's a that's a heck of a top
three
uh you you brought me some books some
bread and books
yeah
some russian bread russian inspired
bread
yeah i mean it's latvian but it's
similar to close enough similar to
what's made in russia and it's made at a
russian bakery and your dad is from
right my dad is from latvia yeah
so you got me some books
beautiful ruins yeah and if you never
read them who cares that's totally fine
you know people give you books and then
you feel like
you just
you're i don't you sort of feel like i i
see this is we'll we'll talk about this
this is part therapy session i don't
feel the need
to to satisfy people's happiness that's
a good thing okay so but they it could
also be a
an opportunity to experience something i
never otherwise would have so beautiful
ruins
it's a book that made me laugh and cry
and it's just a happy story and for some
reason i don't know exactly why but for
some reason
um
when you asked me to come first it just
i thought oh i'm gonna bring a copy of
that book
that's you just felt it came the voice
told you yeah there's others darkness
visible these are more a memoir of
madness compelling harrowing a vivid
portrait of a
debilitating disorder it offers the
solace of shared experience the new york
times this is
a little bit
about this book that reminds me of um
the carl
deisseroth book because he
writes about his own condition in um i
mean he's an amazing writer so he writes
about it in this beautiful way and
oddly enough in some ways it's kind of
delightful so it's not at all a
depressing book at least i didn't find
it depressing at all i don't think it is
um but he writes about
his own experience with depression in
such a beautiful way
um my own copy is full of underlines
um i would have loved that copy too i i
would love to look into the underlines
and the and then the books with notes
those little secrets that people leave
part of why i like paper books is
because i underline i tend to underline
like crazy the the carl dice book is
full of underlines too well i do the
same thing on kindle but
um and then you can actually more
effectively go back to the things you've
underlined because you highlight and so
on but in fact when you underline in
on paper
books
you sometimes never go back
which always makes me sad to the book to
the things you've underlined in the
paper books yeah in the paper books oh i
do i go back
yeah i go back a lot do you wonder what
what the heck you were thinking about
when you wrote something
no well sometimes i underline things
that are well also what i do is i have a
whole file in evernote
of
transcribed quotes from books ones that
i want to save so i might underline a
lot of things in a book and then
maybe like a third of them
i want to write them down somewhere
so i i write those down and i think even
the time it takes to transcribe it is
somehow worthwhile it's like searing it
in your brain
and um and you're reliving the memory
having it read it the first time yeah
and then sometimes i'll pick up books i
even um
and sometimes i just underline sentences
that are it's not the content of the
sentence it's more that it's just a
beautifully written sentence or like a
particularly apt metaphor or something
that's that's really nice um
and i like paper books too because i
bought beautiful ruins i would have
never heard of it i don't think except
one of my favorite things is to go to
used bookstores
actually goodwill sometimes has really
good
big book selections and depending on the
area where you go
um sometimes you find a lot of treasures
there
and what ends up happening a lot is i
end up buying books that i know
sometimes also because i lost all my
belongings at one point so i'll very
often buy books that i've already read
just to have them
and um
but then what always ends up happening
is i'll
find
there'll be a couple of books that i buy
that i've never heard of the author i
don't really know anything about i don't
know anything about the book at all but
something drew me to it and
what i like about that is you're buying
you're buying used books so it costs a
dollar or two so if you made a mistake
like no big deal who cares so but every
time i come back with a book haul
there's usually
at least one
gem that i end up loving and i'm so glad
that i read it and beautiful ruins was
that book for me and i was drawn to it
because of the cover art like i just
loved i just loved the cover and the
colors
and um and then i picked it up and read
the bag and and bought it and
um i also feel bad sometimes buying used
books when the author is still alive
because i feel like if you write a book
you should get the
the royalties so um
and but you get to live with that regret
well also i mean i'll usually end up
putting a picture of leon reading the
book online and then other people buy it
and read it and so i feel like i've made
up for make up for it i've made up for
depriving him of the
royalties i used to live
in cambridge massachusetts
i know it well i used to hang out in the
pit in harvard square with my green and
blue hair when i was very way too young
to be doing that by myself
and there's a guy
that i think has been there for a long
time
sort of between
kendall and central
that would just lay out these books and
sell them i always loved that guy
whoever he was
he had a cool hat he's an older
gentleman
and you could just tell he's seen some
things
i don't know who he is i always wanted
to actually
like talked to him for a long time but i
was too afraid
maybe because i wouldn't be able to
handle what he had to tell me i didn't
because i almost wanted to maintain the
innocence of just okay here's this guy
but he's he was so
every time you would ask him a question
about a book first of all he's read all
of them
oh that's interesting which means he's
traveled
quite a few places inside these worlds
and then you would tell him
i would look at a book right
and you just he would catch you being
curious about it and then he would walk
up to you and then he would start
talking about the book and he would
always
forget that you were there he's almost
like
he's not trying to sell you the books
start talking to himself yeah yeah yeah
like almost like an ex-girlfriend he's
visiting through this book or something
did you buy books from him yeah yeah
definitely but the experience of just
just being there because he lays them
out and people actually that watch or
listen to this
probably will be able to tell me what
his name is because i'd love to find
that guy again i'm sure he's still there
maybe he'll have him on the podcast i
would 100 will
uh but this it's almost terrifying
um i'm not sure i can handle
because he's been through some things
i'm not sure if he's homeless or
or just looks like it
yep
that's sometimes a thing
and uh some of my favorite people
either are harmless or look like it so
okay what's the third one
the uh a confession of a sociopath by
m.e thomas a life spent hiding in plain
sight it's a book i recommend a lot um
because i've read a lot about sociopathy
and i've read all the books by
psychologists and um
and this one's written by a woman who
um understands herself that she is a
sociopath and so it's beautifully
written but i learned i learned more
from that book than from any other book
and
i think i thought about it a long time
ago
i think a lot of
conversations you've talked a lot about
good and evil and
you know whether everybody's really good
or
some people are not good
um
and i think sociopathy is that
is something that i think
the world needs to understand much
better and so that that book helped me
understand a lot and it's beautifully
written and she
tackles all the really interesting moral
questions like
um
you know like what if we were able to
definitively
diagnose people in some way like there
was a
you could immediately identify
who's a full-blown sociopath and then
what as a society would you do with them
because in most cases
you know they're just going to cause
destruction and pain and harm and or
potentially rise to power and become
president
or something
um
so it's i just found that book
fascinating
and we'll return
to this idea because it's fascinating
we'll return to human psychology and
human nature but let's go through um
let's go
through the timeline of your life let's
take a stroll
so uh you wrote that the documentary
about you called bad vegan fame fraud
fugitives is not a documentary it got
some things right something's wrong and
some were quote disturbingly misleading
so let's go through and get things right
today
um
first can i give you a whirlwind summary
the way i understand it and also for
context of people
so 2004
you
matthew kenny and jeffrey chattero
open pure foods and wine in new york
city did i say their names correctly
pure food and wine no they're oh theirs
well yeah matthew kenny jeffrey chattaro
yeah yeah so it's uh
and i'll ask about what it takes to
to
to launch and run a restaurant in new
york city that's a fascinating story in
itself so it's an upscale raw food
restaurant
all right that's 2004 2007 you opened
one lucky duck juice and takeaway
and second and third locations in 2009
and 14.
uh all of those things closed
in uh 2016
15 16 15 and 16 okay
all right 2009
jeffrey lends you 2.1 million dollars to
buy the business outright and matthew is
out
matthew was out earlier than that and
then time passed time passed and i had
um
what was complicated is i had started
the one lucky duck brand on my own
um at first it was a com that was doing
like delivery
it was a it was a com where people could
order ingredients and things and all of
the products that we made and packaged
so we made a bunch of cookies and snacks
and things that were i think different
and
if i may say so myself better than other
um strong words products
already yeah but then about the cookies
but i feel like i can brag about our
food and products because
um i wasn't oh you know a few recipes
recipes early on i came up with but it
was
the people that
worked with me that created really good
recipes and products and
i was just kind of there
curating it all or
um helping to
get it out there what was your favorite
thing that you've created maybe yourself
eat
not you created but this whole
all of these efforts have created in
terms of meal
like
you said cookies what are we talking
about that's a hard question um it's
just okay not the favorite but like
something that pops into memory that
brought you joy
the malomar
everybody loved the malamar it was so
very often we made
like raw vegan versions of things that
people are
um familiar with
so it was a
i think it was pecans it was like a
salty
cookie made with nuts and then covered
in chocolate and then there's a big blob
of
coconut cream um i love coconut which it
didn't taste coconutty
um our ice cream was made with a coconut
also it's like the meat from coconuts
pureed
and then there's some soaked cashews in
there but anyways a blob of vanilla
flavored cream kind of like a
a you know like a healthy natural
version of fluff
i don't know if you're familiar with
fluff
basically every single word you say i'm
not familiar with you should see my diet
i don't
it's like steak and vegetables a fluff
is like a thing that i remember it from
my childhood like peanut butter and
fluff is a ridiculously delicious
combination is it fluffy or is it it's
like a marshmallow it's basically like
like if you softened marshmallows and
made it into a
luxurious amazing goose it's like a fan
and then put it in a jar
okay and then they just spreadable it's
spreadable marshmallows kind of oh i see
i think that's yes so spreadable
marshmallows got it yeah so there's a
big blob i didn't know that existed
that's a thing
fluff i know does everyone for you do
people know about this
oh yeah everybody knows
people i mean i think so people know
about fluff and see i think i went
i i took the road less traveled by you
know i went the
the peanut butter and nutella road in
terms of spreadable things nutella is
like the chocolate version
and then fluff is like the vanilla
equivalent sort of cool but i think
commercial fluff that you buy in the
store is just like sugar and whatever
else they put in there
um
anyway not actually fluffy
it's it's kind of fluffy
okay but it's wet because nutella is
it's like fluffy
yeah it's it so it's like nutella if you
whipped it and then kind of got a little
bit like
a little bit aerated so it's a bit more
fluffy so fluff was a part of the
formula here so it was fun but so the
the coconut cream
that we made
was like a healthy version of fluff
oh kind of nice except it would you know
you could make a
quenelle like a like a little scoop of
it and it would stay in that form
malomars were refrigerated and then
there's like chocolate
um drizzled over that so it had that
like salty sweet thing going on um that
was probably my favorite
that's a dessert
yeah it was like a it was like a dessert
snack it wasn't as you wouldn't order it
on the restaurant menu but in the
takeaway you could get them or sometimes
some people would get them um
shipped on dry ice and pay a lot of
money
like a lot of money to have them shipped
on dry ice
people are funny i know i kind of want
to like name drop because it was tom
brady used to order them oh that's
awesome yeah they would order those
shipped um on ice
to boston
um
yeah
continuing on
in 2011 you meet anthony strangers on
twitter and then in real life
also around this time
i think before you got your rescue dog a
pit bull named leon
yeah 2011 2010. do you remember um it
was september
so because i think he was born roughly
around march i gave him a designated
birthday
of march 10th 2010. why is that why why
march 10th i wrote about the story of
adopting him on my
website a long time ago and then i
reposted it here on my current website
and um what happened
i got weirdly obsessed with
leon before he was leon he was a a dog
in a shelter named quinn
and um i couldn't stop thinking about
him and him specifically him
specifically you saw him and there's
something very special about him i was
trying to convince somebody else to
adopt a dog
so and i alec baldwin yeah and it didn't
occur to me that i like how you didn't
name drop him but you know i'm tom brady
i like it um
so
i was trying to convince him to get a
dog cause i thought you know he should
have a dog
i saw leon's picture and just got
weirdly obsessed with it in a way that i
couldn't really explain and um i was
laying in bed one night and thinking i
just couldn't stop thinking about him
um
the dog and
the paper or the his description in the
shelter bio said that he was roughly
five months old or however whatever it
gave us his age i went back and
it would have been march 20
would have been march of that year that
he was born
and um
i had a cat that i was particularly
attached to
i had two cats brother and sister but
the the boy cat we had sort of like a
something that felt like a
you know like we'd look at each other
and
like there was something there i don't
know what it was but um and in fact when
he got sick i i knew it before he even
had any symptoms it was like something
in the way that he looked at me i knew
something was wrong
and then
uh was it friendship was it
like uh was their power dynamic
cats seem to not really
give a [ __ ] yeah they seem to dismiss
you
usually yeah your your entire worth as a
human being right in a single look
was that there or um he was more
dog-like
he would occasionally fetch like this
little styrofoam thing i had he would
fetch it and bring it back and he was um
friendly and you know if somebody came
over you would jump in their lap um
he was less standoffish than most cats
but there was just something
about the way he would look at me i
don't know and i
maybe
probably in his mind he's just a cat
i give him food whereas in my mind it's
some kind of you know
great soul connection
great but not enough long-running uh
romance not in his kitty mind but either
way so he died in march and i thought um
so
i sort of concocted this
i just thought
um you know that well if he died and
he died on march 10th and so i thought
well maybe leon was born that same day
and that's why
that's why i'm so drawn to him
i don't know
that that mean okay that makes sense but
then you just found that like sort of
when you saw him you just like there's
something it was this picture yeah oh
the picture and you were drawn something
about the personality in the eyes
it was something about his picture i
don't know what it was and um
and
everybody at the time was like what are
you thinking why would you get a dog you
can't you know
you can't even take care of yourself
you're overworked and busy and why would
you get a five-month-old
pitbull mix you know why not get an
older dog that's easier to take care of
and
um for me it was like i don't i don't
want any dog i don't want
my intention isn't to get a dog but
there's something about this dog that i
have to get and so
i went to see him
um
and then i had already filled out an
application it was just
i went to see him and then i it was the
afternoon
and i
sort of decided in my head like all
right i'm coming back to get him i have
to and so the next morning i got on the
subway i went back to get him um and i
was crying on the subway and i remember
thinking that people
i don't like crying in public i cry a
lot but i don't like crying in front of
other people
and um i love it
i thought people on the train looking at
me probably think that
you know i just somebody died or sorry
you're crying on the way there on the
way back on the way there to get him
yeah i don't and i don't know why i was
crying it was just something about it
was overwhelming so
tortillas of happiness or tears of
something something i yeah i think tears
are
overwhelming i
i know i'm like
jumping off but
there was some i don't know i'm trying
was it in your conversation or the book
carl diceroff talks about tears of joy
and trying to explain them and he said
something about how it was like
about
you know because tears of sadness
could
be understood in a having like a
evolutionary purpose um but why tears of
joy and i think he said it was something
about like
hope that could be
like lost
so if you cried at a wedding it might be
like you're crying because their love is
beautiful and you're crying because you
know they could get hit by a bus
tomorrow or something you know like it
had something to do with that and i
thought um
but i thought to me it feels like
overwhelm because then how would that
explain music because music will make me
cry
because it's
it's anything beautiful
like love
you realize you're going to have it's
going to be over one day
or it's just overwhelming it could be
overwhelming i think it's just
overwhelming but over it could like if
you had to explain
like one way to explain it as you're
saying is
it's so awesome
that it breaks your heart that it's
gonna be over this feeling is going to
be over
the
either it's the song or the person
you're going to lose them one day
but even when you're just watching
something that this is completely
ridiculous but i remember one time i
probably was hormonal or something but
it was like an episode of family feud
years ago and the
fam oh no
um
wheel of fortune it was wheel of fortune
and some family like won all this money
and they were so happy like it just they
were so happy they must probably needed
the money or something and i started
crying and i'm thinking
why am i crying but i think it's just i
think it's just like an overwhelming i
think it's overwhelming in some way on
the surface
because is a relief like you feel better
after you cry
but that's not doesn't explain the
crying you feel better after you cry
and you're saying it's overwhelming but
that's on the surface
the question is what's going on
underneath that's
the younging shadow and i don't think
neither you or i can answer that
question right but there's something
going on there's probably something that
touches you in some specific way yeah um
and so you were crying in the subway
so i was crying in the subway very it's
a very new york thing to do
yeah i well that's one of the things i
love about new york is people you can
be weird and
do strange things and nobody's going to
look at you strangely or the fascinating
thing about new york is super crowded
and yet you can still feel super alone
but also energized because a lot of
other things and places
will make me feel depleted but there's
something about the energy of new york
specifically that feels energizing
i mean everybody is
going up about their day excited for a
future they're building and so on and
that that could be energy
sure
sure
it could be overwhelming though
it can be yeah i mean also depending on
what neighborhood
and what part well i'm just talking
about the subway
right yeah and then there's the
musicians
i love new york new york at his best is
a special place i've never lived but
every time i visit
it's so many characters so many
fascinating people yeah and and then
there's a bunch of people always crying
in the subway and you're one of those
people i was one of those people one day
yeah so i befriended some
busking musicians like the the guys that
just
play out on the street these two young
guys playing guitar and i felt like it
was one of those moments where it was
like handed camera because nobody was
paying attention and i thought it was
like
i was so beautiful i may have cried or
almost cried or um but anyway i ended up
becoming friends with them and um
helping them out in some ways and um and
i knew i was like well they're gonna
do really well
um
and now they're like playing
large places and
it's kind of fun to watch via instagram
you know they're going on tour in europe
and they were these two
scrappy guys well now it's just one of
the guys and
um
but they had like no money nowhere to
live nothing
and um another
and they didn't quit they're on tour no
persisted
yeah exactly so um but i cried on the
subway and i got there and um he was
there and i adopted him but it just felt
very
profoundly
um like a force that was beyond me
like i couldn't not get him so he was
the same in person as he was in the
picture
like meaning in terms of like
something
like pulling you towards him like
something yeah when i first met him the
day before he was really distracted
which i think is
um
you know he is a puppy that spends most
of his day in a cage which is not
natural so when i
think let him they let me take him for a
walk and he was kind of you know
distracted and all over the place but
then
when we put him back in the cage
he sort of lay down and looked at me and
i looked back at him and of course i
imagined all kinds of i just looked at
him and i thought all right i'm don't
worry i'm coming back to get you like
i'll i'll get you
so
um
yeah it just
it felt like um
it felt like something that i i had no
choice that i had to do and that was the
beginning of a 12-year
journey together an ongoing an ongoing
one but so i wrote about these things on
my website and um and i think it was you
know among the many things that was
later weaponized by
um
anthony strange's
just oh the fact that because i was so
open to heart about it yeah and also
just it's not like i believe that he was
you know that i was just expressing my
feelings about how i felt going to get
him that there was something about
leon and specifically that i it was like
i felt like i had to get him so
um is there words you can put to your
connection with leon
like is it love
is it
friendship is it
some kind of like what is it
or or are we getting to the crying and
being overwhelmed something you just
can't put words to
yeah it's probably something that's hard
to put words to kind of like i sort of
feel like
love being something that's hard to
define is part of
is the definition of love the fact that
you can't define it you know the moment
you define it you're no longer talking
about love
sort of something like that um
so well my definition of love is
whatever's going on in true romance yeah
i don't know
let me fly through the timeline
before we get to any of the interesting
details so
in 2011 you meet anthony stranges then
in 2012 you to get married
uh 2015
the staff walk out due to failure to pay
from the two restaurants
it reopens in april of 2015 and july of
that year there's another walkout and so
on there's
all this kind of confusing timeline
well it's not to me that's not even
the point is in 2015 there's
chaos happening okay uh 2016 in the
spring pure foods and wine closes closed
in um
2015 2015. okay
there's some factual stuff that's not
yeah maybe correct man to me it's not
that important to me the spirit of the
thing is important
okay may 12
2016 you and your then husband anthony
strange's were arrested after he ordered
pizza using his real name okay in may
2017 you pleaded guilty to stealing more
than two million dollars from investors
and
scheming to defraud as well as this is
from wikipedia
yeah wrong
well let me just finish reading it and
then you tell me why it's wrong in may
2017 you pleaded guilty to stealing more
than two million dollars from investors
and scheming to defraud as well as
criminal tax fraud charges why is
wikipedia wrong and how dare you
well it's about i mean i did plead
guilty to those things which um
i had to oh i was
i got a jury duty summons and i had to
fill out like what charges i pled guilty
to um and i had to go online and look it
up because i didn't
really remember which is i thought that
was interesting
i had to go look it up but actually let
me finish the time because there's one
more point oh yeah
march 16th 2022
bad vegan documentary comes out
where you're interviewed
does they tell the story
some stuff is true sometimes some is not
some is disturbingly misleading as you
said okay timeline over anyway what
what's wrong with the um
how would you elaborate onto the you
pleading guilty for two million dollars
stealing so a lot of people plead guilty
when they're for reasons other than
they're actually guilty
so you know it's
even right now if i knew that i was
gonna have to spend four months or three
and a half
um
at rikers
and i was thinking about this recently
and even if i knew
that i'd be acquitted at the end of a
trial
i very
likely would have just taken the four
months because
um
you know the stress of going through a
trial but in particular be incredibly
stressful not knowing the outcome um and
then money and expense i didn't have and
so
you know people plead guilty all the
time even if they don't think that they
that they should um
and my situation was so complicated
and hard to understand
that it just was the easier thing to do
but also i just was kind of going on the
advice of lawyers and um
so the the choice just so i understand
was to plead guilty
or to go through a lengthy trial
and that trial
would stretch
a long time and it would be extremely
stressful and extremely expensive
because you have to pay the lawyers
right and i didn't have anything
right
and so a lot of people in that situation
might choose to plead guilty and so that
doesn't necessarily mean
the full heaviness of that statement of
guilt
right and i think people plead guilty
all the time in situations where they're
being threatened with uh
like a heavy sentence um
and they sort of feel like they have no
choice but that's kind of part of
a lot of things that are messed up about
the system overall that didn't
necessarily apply in my case but
so we'll talk about to what degree
you're guilty
and what that even means yeah
yeah
it because it depends on
intention i think
um
yeah yeah but then the word intention
also means a lot of things like the word
love
that's true
um all right so the restaurant closed
the first time
when i was away and told to be
off communication
um
and then i by anthony yes
and then
um he told you not to talk to anybody he
told me not to like open email or look
at my phone or whatever
um and so when i
came back
and
had to get it reopen which seemed like
an unbelievably difficult
task and i was kind of shocked that i
was able to pull it off
um you know i worked incredibly hard to
get it reopened
and
you know
because that placement
meant everything to me and so i just
like i just had to get it reopened are
you surrounded by people that were just
angry at you
at that time not well
just the staff and all that yeah but
most of them came back a lot of them
came back i think what was so
unbelievably painful about that whole
time
um was like not being able to tell
anybody what was really going on and in
a sense not really knowing what was
going on myself but not
being able to like having to pretend all
the time was just
like
so you didn't really tell anybody about
uh anthony about him and what was really
going on in part because i didn't really
understand what was going on yeah so
what i did was i raised money to reopen
the restaurant and i think i raised
something like
eight
maybe like 900 grand
and probably 90 of that went to reopen
the restaurant
um and i even made two um
sales tax payments
right before we disappeared
so it just sort of logically seemed
like so i didn't it's not like
all of this money was taken and then he
and i ran off together with a whole
bunch of money
it was like i raised a bunch of money to
reopen the restaurant
you know because i wanted the restaurant
to exist again
and i wanted to you know i wanted to run
it i wanted to reopen the restaurant and
most of that money went to reopen the
restaurant
and then i disappeared
so
um
sort of the the timeline gets a bit
wonky so it's you know this impression
was created that
we ran off with a whole bunch of money
and we didn't so you know if i wanted
to be a criminal and steal a bunch of
money
why would i have put it all back into
the restaurant and reopened it and then
also made
two ten thousand dollar sales tax
payments that i didn't you know
and i also repaid um
you know ten thousand dollars of another
loan i'm you know i was making
repayments and stuff and then boom i
disappear so is your mind
going through a roller coaster here
so could there be multiple use there so
one one mind is like i love this
restaurant i'm going to reopen it i'm
this
um chef business owner
this person and then the other the other
is a human that's in this
uh complicated love affair
it wasn't a love affair okay
these are just words how can i okay what
i don't want to uh lo i say that lightly
uh but also not
because love can make us do
dark things and you can say that's not
love but
okay
the thing that traps us the things that
pulls us in to a connection with another
human being
that's love even when it's abusive and
dark and toxic and all those kinds of
things
in some cases i think like if it's
voluntary but in other cases um somebody
pulls you in
so it's not like you're drawn towards
them they they pull you in so just to
clarify even when it's not physical when
it's when the pull is with words
so it's emotional yeah
okay
where is your mind when you
raise
eight to nine hundred thousand dollars
to open the restaurant
working your ass off to open this thing
okay
making payments and then all of a sudden
disappearing
what where was your mind
um if you had a lengthy conversation
with carl dice roth
in privacy what would you be telling him
as your therapist
i would
probably be asking him questions okay no
i don't get carl as part of this well
actually i have more questions for
andrew hueberman because you know i i've
had to investigate all of these things
myself like dissociation
um
and even
there's a psychologist who believes that
he must have used neuro-linguistic
programming on me which is something
that keith rainery from the nexium cult
he was known to have used that with
people
um and i think neuro-linguistic
programming is kind of the same as
like a sort of like hypnotism
the only reason i know about what nlp is
is because in in what i do there's
something called natural language
processing artificial intelligence stuff
so it has the same
uh like three letters right
uh what was the other thing that nlp
neuro-linguistic linguistic
yeah
anyway
all right well uh we we talked about
andrew
my friend andrew hubermann offline and
you definitely you should do a podcast
with him uh he's a he's a fascinating
he's such a
brilliant and kind human being uh
definitely worth talking to yeah i've
listened to a lot of
a lot of us and you said that
you listen to a lot of his instructions
on getting light
in the morning or whatever during the
day it's very important for your
mental like there's all these kinds of
studies it's good for your for your mind
for your oh and also the other thing
that he got me to do is to try to delay
having coffee so instead of having
coffee right when you wake up i always
drink a lot of water first yeah but then
um instead of having coffee right away
if you wait an hour or an hour and a
half or two hours
then your body is able to
naturally do something that drinking
coffee too soon would sort of blunt that
so then you'll be more tired in the
afternoon
so if you wait an hour and a half or two
hours or as long you know before you
have your first cup of coffee then you
won't be as tired in the afternoon
interesting um there's a lot of does it
work
yes one coffee addict talking to another
coffee addict yes it works and so i try
to get up and do other things first um
before i have coffee
um
so and the light thing also makes a lot
of sense to me um
getting light early in the morning i
have a one of those bright light boxes
um and i would
love to have an apartment that had a
little deck or something where i could
just step outside because when you live
in an apartment you kind of have to like
go all the way outside and then there's
people everywhere and so to get that
early morning light isn't that hard to
do when you're are people good for you
or bad for you what does andrew humor
say about that i'm just kidding it's a
joke okay okay so moving back to where
was your mind that led you to disappear
to uh did you guys go to vegas first and
then tennessee no i kind of refer to it
as like the road trip from hell
it's a very hunter s thompson way to
describe it
right you went back to the back country
maybe it was sort of hunters
thompson-esque except
without actual
drugs
um
that was one of the first questions my
father asked me was was it drugs and i
wished that i could have said yes yeah
because i didn't know how to explain
what had happened
um
but
so really took me away
involuntarily except you know of course
he wasn't holding a gun to my head but
all along it was like a metaphorical gun
was there ever physical abuse
um
no
what would qualify as sexual abuse yes
um but physically no
a couple of times we would get into
slightly physical fights but he never um
i mean he was
big and as
large and blubbery
as he was
he was he was also really strong so
sometimes he would like subdue me but
other than that no there wasn't physical
violence but a lot of people will say
that um
the
psychological violence is
um
i don't want to diminish physical
violence but some people say that the
psychological and emotional violence is
more destructive
it's just that the physical violence is
easier to identify teacher identify and
and it seems kind of more
straightforward
whereas psychological you know and you
have a bruise on your face or you break
a bone and those things hopefully heal
in a visible way
but
psychological stuff
you know
you can't
easily identify or understand or others
can't easily identify it and then you
find yourself crying for no reason at a
beautiful song at some point yes and
it's that that has to do something
happening in the depth
of your mind okay so he took you away
but where was the i mean where was your
mind that was doing both of those things
was able to be taken away
but also was pushing to the
the the
flourishing the reopening and the
flourishing the restaurant
well you know i wouldn't have reopened
the restaurant with and then knowing i
was gonna all of a sudden be taken away
from it and it was gonna get closed
again you know it's like why why would i
do that why would anybody do that
um
and
one of the things that i tried to do
towards the end was i was trying to get
myself off the bank accounts because i
didn't want him to be able to get money
out of me
and so there was uh one time when i
tried to get one of the investors we
went to the bank together to put her on
as the signer and take me off
and because we didn't have the operating
agreement they wouldn't let us do it so
it was like this little snafu
and um
so all of these things are
sort of the opposite of criminal intent
but that's a that's a legal thing what's
what's going on in your mind at this
time
i don't know i mean
well you always did you give yourself
a chance to just think
no and i think that's part of
one of the things that
might have
saved me or
anybody that's pulled into a cult one of
the things that they do is they keep you
exhausted
overwhelmed confused and afraid
um
and so you don't have any time to think
so you're just kind of constantly
running and you're confused and then
things are happening it's funny there's
i have some quotes in my book draft
because i listen to a lot of podcasts i
don't know what the
logistics are of like crediting a quote
from a podcast in a book yeah but i have
a couple i think it was um
andrew huberman on
joe rogan said
something about um
if a
animal if a human or animal i don't know
how he would know the human or animal is
stressed um
and i'm paraphrasing this horribly but
they're they're much more easily prone
to
um
be
not prone to but forced into delusional
thinking
um and so that quote resonated for me
because you know he kept me in this
incredibly stressed out afraid confused
state and then whatever he's sort of
planting in my mind i'm gonna be that
much more likely to just kind of go
along with it
well we'll see how this whole journey
ends let's actually just step back a
little bit and just looking at the
employees at the restaurant and so on
do you have remorse for what happened
especially from the perspective of the
employees and the staff
yeah i mean hurting them was sort of the
last
thing that i would ever have wanted to
do
and
in part i mean there was
financial harm um
but
i don't i don't know whether it's more
important or not but
you know it was
taking a place that
was very much like a family to them
um
and it was as if i destroyed it
and so i think that
because we were so much like a family it
was almost as if
like mom went off the deep end and
got together with some
cuckoo abusive guy and and sort of
abandoned them and they didn't know what
was going on and what was happening and
so do you regret lying to them
i regret lying to anybody
in all of those circumstances but
i wasn't lying
you know
he made me think that you know
everything was going to be reversed and
okay and anybody that
money was borrowed from they would get
it back you know maybe tenfold and so it
was this weird situation of
having like one foot in his reality
and
potentially believing the things he was
saying or
even over time
wanting to believe them more and more
because the alternative was so
the alternative was worse the
alternative was like
was increasingly a bigger and bigger
nightmare so so there's this whole
situation where you're constantly giving
them money you're constantly borrowing
borrowing money well this idea that'll
be repaid like
100x fold right kind of like
so sort of like lying to somebody
because you're planning their surprise
party you think like well i'm lying to
somebody but um but it's because
there's a good reason
yeah you know it's sort of that's not a
good example but
but you could have
not made it a surprise party and be like
pull them in onto the planning of the
party
and be honest about
like everything that's happening not in
a negative way but like
getting in on the fact that okay i just
need to
give money to this guy
but
we'll get
he is
a super rich person of some kind and
he'll
um
repay
i mean i wish i well
because you're holding onto your time i
mean that's part of the torture is that
you're isolated
and
unable
unable to tell anybody
but you're not unable or he was telling
you you're not allowed to say anything
to anybody i mean you're choosing not to
say anything
but it's because of the sort of the
weight of it
because it's embarrassing to sort of
is it embarrassing it's something i mean
what why do you not tell others
you know
what what is that what's what what's
happening to the mind where you don't
tell others
i don't know you're part of why the
story you know everything that happened
is hard to
summarize and talk about
in any concise way is that
so much of it happens in this very slow
slow slow way and
um
you know people always use the whole
like frog and boiling water example
um so that by the time you realize
you're [ __ ] it's too late
um
and it and it seems
hard to believe or understand to other
people because they see where you are or
where you ended up
and they think well how did you let that
happen and well i don't know i yeah
would i have willingly destroyed my life
and hurt all the people i care about and
you know allowed my mother to get hurt
and
i wouldn't have ever ever willingly done
that so something else must have
happened and that's um that's the part
that's difficult to understand let me
ask you about another hearty question
yeah do you deserve most or all of the
blame
for the failure of the business
or are others at fault too
well the business didn't fail it was
doing well
and so
it's closing closing it's like it was
destroyed
and who deserves the blame for that i'm
asking from your perspective when you
think about it in in the privacy in your
mind
are you angry
at anthony are you angry yourself
both i think that
um
in the privacy of my own mind and
to everybody listening
um
it's
i feel responsible
i feel responsible in the same way that
if you
kind of did something if you were
driving you did something stupid and
caused an accident in which other people
died
you would feel i think horrifically
responsible
and you'd blame yourself because maybe
you looked away or checked your phone or
something
um
but it you didn't intend to kill those
people of course
so for me it's like
i didn't intend to kill
you know sometimes i say like my own
child i don't know if that's offensive
to some people but it's like as if i
killed my own
child it was it was a business but it
was special
um
so i don't feel
guilt i feel responsibility
and then
um
you know i'm angry at him even though
that anger is pointless
okay because this has come up
let's continue
uh with the hard questions
are they gonna get easier they're gonna
get it okay
most of them are easy
um this is this is fun we're having fun
you post it on instagram
the
ending no i'm gonna cite instagram like
it's shakespeare okay
the ending is disturbingly misleading
but still i'm very grateful for this
coverage let's talk about the
documentary
in quotes documentary
i'm okay with the criticism and judgment
but would rather be based on what's true
and then you say a couple more sentences
and then you say leon who has his own
instagram account yes one lucky rescue
dog
says hello he loves you all even if you
call me a quote defective arrogant
sociopath
it's all okay
so the hard question
do you think
you are in part a sociopath
no
would you know it if you were yes how
does this work so what have you learned
from reading this book i had all these
interesting thoughts about all these
sort of questions and thoughts about it
because um
the book i'm reading now that i'm only
about a third of the way through she
talks about um
some of the things in the brain
structure that are particular to
sociopaths
and so then it makes you think well what
if that could be
tweaked in some way like could you
unsociopath a sociopath
is it nature or nurture i suppose is the
question i think it's both
um i think it's genetic and then it's
like genes that are turned on
by
things like a particularly violent
childhood or some sort of dysfunction so
i think somebody could have the gene
it's not turned on and then
um
the sociopaths
have the gene and it's turned on
so so sociopath means that you're not
able to be empathetic or you're
generally not empathetic to the to the
suffering of others or to the emotions
of others i mean it's a hollowness so
it's like you don't have
um
just completely lacking the capacity i
mean it's tragic because they
wouldn't understand or feel love
but it's like a hollowness
um and
and then
something also about the wiring and i
think also because of that hollowness
they're able to
incredibly quickly
look at others and identify their
insecurities and
buttons
and weak spots
so they're incredibly good at
manipulation is that because they're
just able to objectively observe the
situation
i wonder probably in part but there was
some other explanation related to the
brain structure that i read somewhere
that made sense to me and i won't like
remember it because i don't usually
you're not andrew huberman who's no
reference like i'll listen to it
perfectly yeah every single line from
every book or paper he's ever read yes
right i don't remember things in that
way i try to usually remember the
conclusions right so like i might
remember that
he he might give a whole long
explanation about why it's good to do
this or to take this supplement
that's a bad habit i have sometimes i'll
order supplements and then by the time
they arrive i've forgotten why
i forgot why just take them all supposed
to say thompson but the healthy version
i hope we get to talk about food because
i feel like
yes you have a brain that should be
fed only the best food
oh wow so we can talk about that later i
have a lot of philosophies about that
but certainly fluff is not
in the best what is best we'll
definitely talk about food
throughout what is best
that makes me think of conan
and i just talked to oliver stone who i
didn't realize wrote conan the barbarian
uh do you know that in my head i i
pictured conan o'brien that's what
he's also saying
wait why i love him but i when you said
that i was like why did that make you
think of conan o'brien
yeah yeah i love him so much such a
brilliant human yeah
sociopathy sociopathy yeah so it's stuff
about the brain fine
but how do you know you're not a
sociopath would you know it
am i a sociopath how would i know it
how you know
well having listened to a lot
why wouldn't i be able to be good at
faking it isn't that what well
there's the master and the cover of this
book i don't think we would be doing the
work don't worry you'd probably be
running for office or
you know a trader on wall street or
one of the things about sociopaths is
they um
they kind of need like this stimulation
of risk and
danger
um
well
i need
okay sure
more than average i like um okay
but wall street
there's a fakeness
like i don't like the fakeness of what
the game of it
yeah that's why i left
i didn't i just
it was a strange environment okay
so you're not you're not a quote
defective arrogant sociopath what does
defective even mean i know well i think
that somebody had just called me that
and i think that
you know it's easy for people to say
like don't read the comments but it's
hard
not to because then also you'd miss the
beautiful ones
or sometimes like you have to go on
there to to check a private message and
you just stuff
it's there people saying terrible things
so um
i try to
people say you know don't pay attention
to the comments it's hard not to but i
try to
even with the documentary you try to
still kind of
see
to look
to look for the for the good ones for
the kind ones for the support there were
overwhelming kind comments and so that
that
helped and felt a lot better but
sometimes um
sometimes the
the negative comments
are based on you know they're based on
false information so if somebody unders
if somebody knew everything that
happened
and then wanted to judge me or say
things like that's
somehow
at least that's all right but
um so you think people saying these
things based on
um
things that are totally false it's just
it's hard it's it's hard to
just let that go um
yeah but i know that people also say
things
you know for their own
personal
reasons i had a fascinating exchange
with somebody who direct messaged me
and called me trash
um you responded i responded because it
was i
no it was amazing so okay i would do
this
wow it's sort of like a
i might be procrastinating or but
i would scroll through
because the private messages were
overwhelming and there's still just this
massive backlog that i'll never probably
get to read but the one that called you
trash as a pickup as an opener you're
like
this is interesting i just was in a mood
yeah and so
i responded
and i wish i hadn't deleted it because i
i sort of deleted a bunch and then i was
like oh why did i delete that one
because i was curious what exactly i
said to him but i responded to him um in
a nice way
and then he responded back and then it
started this whole back and forth
conversation
um so he was kind quickly or no yes and
then also like wanted to get to know me
and lives in pennsylvania and was like
i'll come to you i'm like
do you realize if we you know if somehow
this just turned into like that would be
our how did you meet story well he
called me trash
online that's pretty good yeah he ended
up having such an insightful
comment
i just found it interesting and i think
he at first he said i never imagined
you'd reply which is you know it's like
part of the whole thing with social
media although this guy wasn't anonymous
um
was not anonymous no he had a i think he
had a private account but it's like his
name and his face was there
and people forget that you're a human
being when they message you exactly
folks when you message me i'm a human
being
so
i told him that that was you know like
that that i was hurtful yeah and um and
i guess i wanted to understand more why
he said it and
it was surprisingly insightful but he
said something about again i wish i
hadn't deleted it that
he
um
he was like i guess i was just
angry because
um
like that guy
he said something like i guess i was
just angry because that guy got you and
i would have you know so it made me
think of the whole like sort of
in-cell jealousy
thing that can be very terrifying if
you're
female is that like if you reject a guy
they might turn around and be
violent or angry at you yeah and um
so his
well to be fair there's a dormant anger
in probably all of us
i believe there's a capacity for cruelty
and anger and destruction all of us and
the whole struggle of life is
to uh emphasize the good stuff
yeah yeah so it's not just an insult
thing it's true for men and women both
capable of cruelty that's that is very
true but this one guy so and then you
put on my therapist hat because we we
started what do we start with
um
i already forgot but the the oh back to
sociopath no
no just
um you know maybe it's not the best idea
to answer comments that start with your
trash i don't do it all the time it just
i happened upon that one and i was just
in a certain mood i was just in a
certain mood and let's let's and i like
further offline sort of yeah um
discuss this mood that you're in because
it might get you in trouble at some
point in your future
okay
uh
um can we just jump back speaking of um
guys that say as an opening to your
trash how did you and
anthony strange's meet can we jump
around and tell some of the details here
because that i believe the document
doesn't cover that that well it's not
clear there's some twitter interactions
and you've kind of assumed
um
by the way i do think you need some
social media coaching on this because i
think
you know
um i you know i have i have some uh
uh books you need to read i think
uh some manuals on how to use twitter
properly but anyway the that apparently
you kind of thought that this person uh
who turned out to be
what was his name he called himself
shane fox but
he turned out to be anthony strange's
that he was somehow friends with al
baldwin because of their friendly
interaction on twitter
and so you started interacting with him
and then there was
how did that escalate quickly to um
it escalated slowly
and i think um
i'm sure it was intentional because had
i met him right away i would have
probably thought like oh
he's not what i thought he was and no
thanks
um
but
it was a long time it was many weeks of
back and forth conversation
um digitally one way or another so it
was you know via twitter and then
via direct message and then
we both played words with friends back
then and we would message in words with
friends and then eventually you know we
exchanged phone numbers how does word
with friends work what's that
i know that's a popular
game is that scrabble it's like scrabble
and you're playing other people and then
there's like a chat function
yeah and you can chat with them right so
you were
this intellectually stimulating game and
you were what like flirting and that
kind of stuff
like
witty banter
yes
aka flirting
yes and but but um
all of that lasted a really long time
and and he would give me like little
tiny bits and pieces of information
about himself
that made him seem kind of mysterious
this is a dark mysterious man who was a
navy seal
strong
yeah and he would always imply things
versus say them outright so you're kind
of always guessing and filling things up
clint eastwood type of character he's
not going to say it outright he's right
he's a clint eastwood type of character
he's not going to say it outright right
he's just going to act badass yeah okay
all right
um and plus intellectual
because the word words with words with
friends is that that's the thing by the
way so what is it i think it still
exists yeah but i i i
um i feel like if i started playing it
again i would i'd get a little addicted
and yeah um but stick to the coffee one
of the interesting things is that
i used to think that he like used an app
to look up things but then he would do
it in front of me
he could like look at he was really good
at it and he could look at the board and
just like
come up with you know a hundred point
word that i'd never even heard of
so i think he had a little bit of that
something going on in his brain that was
like
um i don't know a little
rain manish or something in the way that
he was able to
recall i think his recall is incredibly
it's important if you if you lie a lot
if you lie a lot yeah to have good
recall okay so uh when uh it's okay so
how did it escalate slowly from
with friends to meeting in real life
like what you know what i mean what okay
i know i know it's not a love affair
that said
um
when did you kind of get hooked
by the
oh i wonder you know
like fall in love just a slow
yeah what did you fall in love it was a
slow
process
and i think um he found me at a time
when there was sort of a perfect storm
of the right conditions for me to to
fall into
um
whatever i fell into with him
um because that was
heartbroken for the first time in my
life
where was the heartbreak coming from i
had split with my boyfriend
of four years
um
and that broke out
yeah i mean it was i knew it was a
relationship that i knew
would end
even when i got into it in the first
place um because
he's 15 years younger than me
and surely that can't be the only
character the only reason it wouldn't
work
i need to also give you a book on love
what's it called i i'm i'm gonna write
it i don't know okay just because
there's nothing called a joke
didn't bring okay
there's no book on twitter and there's
no book that i love
a lot of people keep trying to write
love that i really like that i think you
might like but um
like love languages i still have to read
that no it's called on love
all right i can't wait but i'm gonna
read the cliff notes bye it's short by
this guy named alan de botton
i don't trust him already no it's funny
and it's beautiful and shocking that he
wrote it when he was very young
um and i first heard him on a krista
tippett podcast
um
that's how i end up reading a lot of
books is like you hear somebody in a
podcast
um
so
so
you were heartbroken you knew it was
going to work i knew it was going to
work because the age difference
that's just because the age difference
also you know i just knew that
eventually he'd want to move on and
probably he'd find somebody
younger and or
was young enough that he still needed to
go have a bunch of other experiences
and um
you know probably wanted a family or
whatnot eventually so he was
21 and i was 34
when we first met
um
but and but then we ended up living
together for four years and it was the
most
drama-free
like there's no drama
and i had just come off
my prior relationship was matthew kenny
which was very um
dark in many ways and full of all kinds
of
yeah and i i just couldn't couldn't
handle that so can i ask you a personal
question yes
between us and
be two best friends
um is there a part of you that's
attracted to the drama
and the chaos
now
looking back
i feel like that happens a lot and
maybe there was at some point but i
don't think so because
you know part what made that
relationship work
um
with his name was tobin
was
that there was no drama
not at all and i don't think i could
have handled it and i feel that way now
too like i just couldn't i can't like
fighting or any kind of like
like people being passive aggressive i
can't i can't handle that
um
so you you've had enough storms now you
want the calm
yes yeah um so you knew it knew it
wasn't work i knew it wasn't gonna be
forever well that that could be just
uh insecurity and cynicism but fair
enough and then the heart was broken
yes and now the heart was broken
and fragile
and um
there to be manipulated in some sense
yes and there's another
person that i heard that i quoted my
book saying that when you're heartbroken
you're you can't rely on your instincts
somehow your instincts are compromised
when you're heartbroken um
and maybe i'm just like looking for
excuses
i don't know why this happened but
but i was heartbroken and then um
i like to see people in their heart
broken because it's like
um
shows how much they really loved
somebody
you know
yeah it's it's it's sad but like
sometimes love doesn't reveal itself
as richly
when you're in it versus when you lose
it
right that's probably true
anyway so your judgment wasn't good
great so now you're
so you're lonely and you're super busy
running the restaurant but when you get
home you're lonely
or like in between
yeah and i was kind of overwhelmed and
um
but i'm sure you were getting a lot of
really positive attention from other
guys to
while new york
or too busy well no because because it
was a restaurant there was constantly
you're like constantly meeting people
um and really interesting people and
new york is full of
a lot of
um
interesting people
and you're you know attractive
yes so you why are you connected to some
uh
mysterious distant man from somewhere
else playing over words was because well
i think now looking back i think it's
because i felt like he understood me
and um
you know what was that feeling from
coming from you think like what
why did you why does one feel that
you're understood
one thing that made me
extra easy to target is that i'd written
a lot of very personal blogs
and things so
in addition to him asking me questions
and me
probably just being insanely open and
answering whatever he asked me i'd also
written and posted a bunch of personal
blogs some of them i've
reposted on my new website and then some
of them i haven't but
in one of them i go into detail about
my frustrations
um professionally in growing the
business
and
having read that
and being a very smart person
he would have known kind of precisely
what to say
to get me
um to get me drawn in
so i think by waiting so long before we
met in person he'd already
he'd already gotten me hooked in a way
that was gonna then
make it possible for me to
you know see him and even though he
doesn't look like i thought he did i'll
make excuses for it or
um i mean it's a dangerous thing about
um when people and i'm not saying i fell
in love with him in this way that i feel
like there's another explanation for the
what felt like
love
um
but
when people fall in love quickly there's
like danger that
um
because
that's what happens first that the more
you learn about them you'll sort of
rationalize away
things that might be red flags or things
that you don't like
so
i think um
i think it's
safer to
fall in love in a
when you get to know somebody not in the
context of
dating them like
like jim and pam on the office
did you watch the office yeah because
yeah of course i watch the office
british office is better
strong words but yes um but yes so
well uh yeah fine
true it might be but i also romantic
yeah i like the romantic you could fall
for you yeah it's fine you but just i
think the better lesson is yes
that's one thing to say but the other is
like when you see the red flags
notice them be a little better about
noticing them
but what if even amidst the passion what
if like a brilliant woman
kind of threw herself in your path right
she she having because talking on a
podcast is a little bit like having a
blog where you over share because people
learn everything about you what you like
what you what what you don't like what
your wants and dreams and you know so
some woman like could
pretend to run like throw herself in
your path seemingly accidentally
and then you meet and she has a russian
accent
and probably works for fsb
no but whatever she is who she is and
then um
and then she sort of slides into the
conversation like a a quote from the
idiot right yep yeah yeah yeah and
you're like
boom
yep right and then but then but but
she's not who she that's all up pretend
and so you very quickly could fall in
love with her
and she's
gonna turn out to like
enjoy the game of destroying your life
yep
uh you know that or it's the love of my
life it could be but not if she did all
those things intentionally but you you
don't really know
but you have to then pay attention to
that's that's the dark aspect here you
mentioned blog
like i love i love when people have like
stuff about themselves online because
you get to really learn i mean i'm a fan
of podcasts i'm a fan of people it's i
love learning about them the personal
stuff and so on
um hopefully for
for good reasons so the person you can
people you connect with
the good ones are the ones that are
going to be very sort of empathetic
and the bad ones are the ones that are
going to be fake empathetic
like they're going to learn everything
about you and use you to manipulate you
as opposed to learn everything about you
to fall deeper in love with you as a
friend or as a romantic partner or like
genuine curiosity yeah genuine curiosity
like there's something you're drawing
like imagine your dog leon had a blog
after
oh yeah he does not yeah that's true he
kind of does yeah
as
when you met him right then you'd be
like what is this what what is there
that's pulling me towards this creature
this this this entity like what is there
and it'd be fascinating to learn more
and then you fall in love with the the
details not just with this some kind of
ethereal thing yeah you don't know yeah
you have to pay attention to the red
flags you have to yeah i think one of
them actually is is somebody who doesn't
have that kind of i mean plenty of
people are private and they don't put
stuff out about themselves online for
all kinds of very valid reasons but
um
somebody who does share a lot about
themselves personally is
um
maybe there's examples but it's probably
not a sociopath if they're sharing all
kinds of sure sure but i mean on the
other side um
when you meet people yeah i still like
the falling in love
because the red flags whether you see
them early or later it doesn't matter
i'd rather see the red flags right away
i go in hard intensely like
uh and to clarify by going hard i mean
like
you know um
no small talk
just get to know a person get to know
quickly
get to know the person challenge travel
with them travel with them is a really
powerful one road trip from hell or not
go on a road trip and find out if it's a
road trip from hell yeah
but you might so if there was somebody i
was it was also a male perspective
destructive relationship with where we
had already fallen in love and then
went for the first trip yep um in a
situation where we were like had to
borrow
uh i guess he was sharing he was still
sharing his car with his ex-wife so we
had to go to the garage to pick up the
car to go on his little trip and um so
you're literally baggage the egg
yes
so
but but um
something happened where the the garage
attendant
was like wanted more identification and
it was a pain in the ass and anyway this
guy was so unbelievably rude to
the garage attendant like just nasty
and i was
completely shocked and disturbed and we
got in the car for this long car ride
and i i was like not saying anything and
really shocked
and then he noticed that and was very
concerned and i
explained you know like i just i never
i would never treat somebody that way
and then he
pretended
to get incredibly upset and to feel
horrible and remorseful about it and
it was like all we talked about for the
next few hours and then i kind of
thought like well okay you know i can
get over that and then the relationship
continued and it was a dark and
destructive one whereas
you know had i seen him behave that way
before we were in a relationship
i would have known to back away
okay but at my the lesson you could
still walk away
you could still walk away but and no you
can't well
i could have walked away at any point
with i call him mr fox because it's sort
of de-personalizes him um
but
i could have walked away from him at any
point in time but that's the whole
that's kind of the whole point of what
they do and the whole reason why people
don't understand it
um i mean it's it's this
it's like being in a cult of one
so
the people who've been in cults and
gotten out we understand each other very
well
um because the same
psychology was used
the same psychological tactics were used
on us
and then we experienced the same thing
on the other side of it which is it's
hard for us to understand and it's hard
for other people to understand and
everybody's saying that would never
happen to me or they're saying i don't
get it because you're smart how could
you let that happen why didn't you leave
why didn't you walk away
and
on the other side of it we don't have
the answers or it takes a really long
time of self-reflection and reading and
investigation to try and figure out
how it is that it happened and why
didn't we walk away
um no it's definitely i mean it's
definitely hard at every level
and
i i just think that
even for more subtle for sort of not
outrageously toxic relationships but
like normal toxic not normal like a
little bit toxic there are some people
that kind of thrive on conflict yeah but
you could just still just be self-aware
like i think you've talked about give
yourself time to think about the red
flags
and
like i pride myself on being able to
walk away you have to you have to think
like uh
is this
is this the kind of thing i can live
with
in friendship and business partners and
um
and because the little things that
bother you turn out to be big things
down the line
so yeah so it could be
less romantic but i feel like
getting to know somebody
slowly over time is yeah it's a smarter
thing it's safer [ __ ] it though
but that's again my you know
russian
slash ukrainian
male perspective anyway
so
meeting mr fox
anthony that's a chapter title in my
book meeting mr fox meeting mr fox so
you're working
uh on a book about this
i'm almost done
it's taken a really long time can you
define it almost done
because i you know i've said that
it's like it's when people say like um
you know they're leaving like i'm i'm
almost in the car
right and they they actually not really
they're not really they haven't even
started showering yet or something so
yeah i do i think i probably need some
like therapists to work with me on this
um are you usually late to things
no
okay
i'm usually
oh i sent you a text message because i
was early when i got here yeah
and i said that i'm um um
because of
i think i said my crippling fear of
being late
i'm like always early
so i'm loitering outside like a weirdo
but glad to come in
if it's not too early
the crippling fear of being late makes
me chronically early and today is no
exception
yeah it's interesting i got here before
i before i rang the bell yep i was
outside for a little while like just
killing time going i'm way too early
but it's really hot out
oh that's true yeah cause i'll yeah i'll
i always air like i was very early to
the airport and then i had all this time
to kill but that's fine with me because
that's actually time i appreciate
because i can
um
write things or you know i worked on my
book draft on the on the airplane
um
mostly editing
um which it needs a lot because it's
really long it's in word count so all
the things are already completed and
you're just editing down now i wish
it's it's in five parts and i've written
one through four
and five part five is like
the chapters are all there but some of
them are messy some of them are some of
them are just like a few paragraphs some
of them are just notes
some of them are done
so
i am kind of almost like five parts and
part five is not quite finished um
but i've been editing along the way
so so this is gonna come out in 2023 i
think you mentioned
so it won't come off for a bit or we'll
figure it out
uh what have you learned about yourself
from putting some of these things down
on paper
what's like the darkest thing you've
realized about yourself
from writing the darkest
um well
one of the things that was fascinating
is reading through all of our the
correspondence between him and me that i
was able to find because he deleted all
our emails but he he didn't i think he
thought he deleted all of our g chats
but he didn't
well so he had access to your email yes
deleted on that side too and he yeah he
had access to my email most of the time
and then at the end was also emailing
people as me which was
incredibly mortifying to come home and
then get back into my old email and find
that and i think um he was also texting
people as me and those i'll never know
unless somebody
brings it to my attention because after
a certain date in 2015 he had my phone
and he had exclusive access to my phone
and email so i wasn't looking at it
until
i got out until after we were arrested
um and i was out on bail on my sister's
and it took me a long time to get back
into my gmail because i had to verify
who i am and
um and i never got my phone back so i
don't know what he texted to other
people as me after that time but
anyway i was able to recover
um
a lot of our g chats
which we
use that'll i don't know why people
don't use it anymore but it used to be a
thing yeah so it was like if you work
with people and you use gmail it's a
really easy way to just message back
it's a chat client within uh google but
i think google shut it down already
right now
i think it's still there okay
and nobody nobody i used to talk to
people on there and nobody talked to me
anymore
and so i i i'd rather you
thank you
i i just i don't
yeah
people don't love google social products
for some reason the social network they
tried several times google plus
it just dies out something about it it's
like when microsoft tries to do stuff it
just doesn't feel right
anyway it is it is very lonely
in that google chat window it makes
total sense though anyway so that was
still there so you're reading through
them so finding you know being able to
go back and read and then i kept finding
like
more layers of stuff
um and including a journal that i didn't
find the the d.a the prosecutor found
written by me my journal that i thought
he'd thrown away i didn't know it
existed so
um
somehow he still had it and they found
my my journal
which was for the year
2014
and the very beginning of 2015.
um this is after you got
this is in the middle of it it was in
the middle of it yeah so reading that
was fascinating
um yeah what what's some interesting
things there
what was it
was your mind completely detached
it was weird because
no like were you concerned were you in
love were you afraid i was not in love i
was afraid i definitely write repeatedly
in there that i'm afraid of him i also
rep write repeatedly things like i don't
know what's going on like please let
this be over
please let this be over please let this
be over and then in a sort of
if i try to remove myself and look at it
as if i was a different person
it's sort of heartbreaking because i was
trying so hard to be positive
and um
and that didn't work out you know trying
to be positive
so
but
when i
it turned up later in the process and um
my lawyer at the time
called or something and said um you know
the d.a has your
or the prosecutor that they have your
journal
i haven't read it yet but as soon as i
get a pdf copy i'll send it to you so
that was sort of weird to think that
everybody's reading my journal which you
know you don't write it thinking people
are going to unless you're like a
historical person and then later on you
think people are going to
print from it
but you're not nobody's writing it's
just a matter i can just imagine like
like a 14 year old thinking they're
going to be a historical person right
right well no i mean like you know
presidents who keep journals and then
they're later on sure sure yeah so you
write it you don't think everybody
anybody's gonna read it and so that was
a weird feeling and then also just not
knowing
having you know not remembering what i
wrote
um
so i think it was the next day i got she
sent me a pdf copy of it and i read it
really quickly because i could read my
own it was a pdf so it was like xeroxes
of the pages it was in my own
handwriting which i could read really
fast because even though it's messy i i
wrote it so i could read it really fast
and i read the whole thing and was
crying because i thought okay
finally
like
surely nobody could read this and think
that i intended to commit crimes
and so i thought like i thought that
journal was just
gonna fully exonerate me and they would
like you know if not drop the charges
like it would just be like okay well you
know some bad things happened you're
responsible you know
here's probation
but it didn't seem to make any
difference which was strange
um but anyway so the journal
and then also
finding all of the correspondence
between not all of the correspondence
between him and me but the g chat
correspondence between him and me
um
to me
so you know all of that in its entire
like i wish that everything could have
been
kind of
put out there as evidence like the more
they turned up the better for me because
i wanted them to see everything
and
are just so many examples in the
correspondence between him and me where
he's you know threatening me and
um you know
lying to me and telling me that if i
don't do what he says my whole life will
be destroyed and i'll lose everything i
ever cared about all kinds of things
like that but
what was
what i still don't quite understand
and what uh one of my lawyers said why
all of that wasn't as useful as i
thought it might be is because
so much of that correspondence i'm
um
like sarcastically angrily i'm yelling
at him i'm mad at him i'm like [ __ ] you
i'm making fun of him i call him names
um
i'll say to him like you're lying why
should i believe you you told me you'd
pay me back before but you didn't
so it seems like it doesn't
it seems like it doesn't make sense like
how is it that if i say to him you're
lying you're a liar
that i still but so then what would
happen is i'm reading those that
correspondence
and then it stops for a while maybe
because i was with him in person yeah um
and then i'll look at like my timeline
of things and i'll see like oh i sent
him a wire for 80 000 like
yeah how do you explain your ability to
still
uh joke around and
also to be
like mean to him in a joking way like
you know couples can do that
i guess like
i mean there's r there's like cruel ways
of doing that and then there's like
humorous ways just like you're talking
[ __ ] whatever
uh you're able to do that still and yet
you're sending over
the money and are afraid like how can
you be those two things
like as opposed to completely shutting
down
well
i don't know i mean these are all
interesting questions that i have as
well like how is it that i was
functional yeah
and yet also doing these things and so
the year that we were gone is like a
different
level because i no longer was running
the business but
the thing about dissociation is that
you're functioning but like your
feelings and your thinking are detached
in some way so that like you're
functioning and people wouldn't
look at you and go that person's
dissociating because you're functioning
you seem normal but somehow in your head
there's you're like
disconnecting your feelings and you're
thinking
so so you're still able to be like like
the the the game of social interaction
like being witty and so on all that kind
of stuff you still for me i think it's
like a coping mechanism too because all
like if i went i haven't been to a
funeral a long time but if i went i'd
probably like find
absurd thing you know
or
i'll tend to like either make jokes or
want to make jokes at really
inappropriate times even in tragic times
because it's almost like a
like a defense
mechanism i think you said uh you told
me you like dark humor yeah
i i
my next-door neighbor is michael malus
he's a anarchist i have one of his books
the hero deer reader dear reader yeah
and he loves he he embodies dark humor
trolling and dark humor and and is
underneath it the sweetest human being
because he's writing a book now the
white pill that's really focused on
stalin and the holomore there's
basically atrocities throughout the 20th
century and
i think he needs the dark humor to
release the valve
i think there's something about
incredibly good
the most offensive comedians
tend to have
the kindest hearts i think this is my
theory people like
ricky gervais who you know who goes out
and insults people and makes jokes that
people find horribly offensive and crude
and
um
and
and yet
you know is a huge animal rights guy and
and appears to be an incredibly sweet
and kind
person and sensitive and
you know howard stern people who are
like incredibly crude
very often are
in my experience to the extent that i've
gotten
either to know people personally observe
them
learn about them in other ways but the
almost like the the more crude and
offensive the
the comedian or the person they they
tend to have the kindest
like yeah i don't know if it's a
universal rule but yeah i see what you
mean and he lost me with howard stern i
he seems like not a good person oh no
he's such a good person underneath it oh
yeah such a good person he's just said
so much
so i'm friends with rogan he says so
many ignorant things about rogan but i
suppose that's um
so i haven't heard i haven't i haven't
listened to howard stern in a long time
and i also think that people who say
bad things about rogan
don't listen to his podcast right
because if i've i've listened to his
podcast and like people think that
i think people would assume that i don't
like him because
or
the whole like vegan thing and he's all
about meat and they would think that i
would think
no
i mean because i've listened to enough
of his podcast i've i've heard the one
where he talked about why he hunts
and um
whereas if i if i only knew him via his
instagram i might think he's an [ __ ]
yeah but having listened to all of his
uh not all i don't listen to all of them
there's a ton of them um but having
listened to a lot of his podcasts enough
to know that
um
you know he's an extremely kind person
with all the best intentions
and i think that a lot of that judgment
comes from people who are just seeing
little clips yeah because it's probably
easy to take little clips from him that
sound yeah the lesson there is just not
make judgments on on people without
getting to know them especially and you
have no excuse when the content is out
there like don't be lazy yeah
i try that's i'm yeah i'm very careful
when
um
you know a lot of these cases
um you know like the the dep herd thing
or oh uh johnny depp and elizabeth
holmes and anything like
controversial and sometimes that makes
me
i can't think of an example but very
often um
like when somebody criticizes something
or something becomes controversial
that's what gets me to want to
understand it better so then i'll go
like read the book that everybody's mad
about yeah it's hard to know what's true
though so i i try i try to have humility
and always assume i don't really know
the full story and keep pulling at the
strength keep learning more and more but
even then like
the more you learn the more you realize
things are
complex
uh what do you think about as a small
tangent
um johnny depp amber heard trials going
on it's a quick pause it's gonna resume
next week so again this is one of those
situations where
you know i have very limited information
because i'm also not sitting there
watching the trial yeah have you watched
any of it uh little bits of it and i
it's like i know that if i go there and
then i'm gonna want to watch it all yeah
it's good i know i really it's raw human
relationships it is most toxic at its
most
deep also because there's you can tell
there's love probably still there's love
which is the interesting thing they
probably still love each other even
though they hate each other
um and like there's a lot of lying going
on
it looks like it's amber heard lying to
to my
foolish eyes it seems like she's lying
non-stop but
you know
i want to know the full story
and we'll never get to know it but you
see this raw
like postmortem on a relationship on a
love affair that was clearly passionate
there was clearly something deep of a
connection there and it just
that's the sad thing about love it can
destroy you as much as it can uplift you
so there that would be also used to
destroy people yeah to manipulate and
all that kind of stuff yeah right so
people who
um feel that strongly
are i think particularly vulnerable um
yeah it's
it's hard to talk about because
i've dipped into
like a podcast or something where other
people are we're discussing bad vegan in
like a pop culture way
and they're analyzing it and it's so
annoying to listen to because i'm like
oh my god that's totally wrong that's
totally wrong well if they only knew
this well i have nope that's wrong so it
you know yeah listening to other people
analyzing um
my situation or my psychology when they
don't have all the information has been
really frustrating
the difference i did
there's a difference because the world
doesn't know much about you except for
the netflix documentary right there's a
lot more information about both johnny
depp and amber heard and the trial is
revealing the real people this is so
interesting but i haven't watched at all
okay but but there's a difference
between a documentary and like a raw
human being exactly the real trial you
can see the body language
the
it's so interesting that i think you
could tell the difference between a
person
who is full of [ __ ] and not
no
i'm not sure
yeah it's another i'm gonna i can't
remember and sorry so i keep
interrupting you but on top of this
they're actors too which is very
annoying because right exactly because
like i don't know if they're putting it
but sure as hell looks like amber heard
is putting on
um
like a soap opera act soap opera meaning
like really bad acting
and lies but i would say all of these
things are really hard
people would say about me i don't look
like a victim and
i don't mind you interrupting me because
andrew hueberman said that's that means
you're interested in the conversation
you said it was a good thing
so you don't have to apologize i think
interrupting me nobody keeps coming up
but i keep thinking of these that that's
one of the things that andrew told me
that i'm like i are you sure because it
just doesn't seem like an [ __ ] thing
to do i don't i guess it depends on the
context if we're in a business meeting
and and somebody you know talks over you
to kind of make their point heard but if
it's a one-on-one situation then it's
not
i could argue anyway forever but so a
long time ago i listened to there was a
audio call um an audio that was released
of a
taped argument between johnny depp and
amber heard
um and i don't remember why
like which one of them had taped it and
if they knew it was being taped but it
was like an hour and a half and i
listened to it almost like you would
listen to a podcast where i was doing
other things like cleaning my apartment
and i was fascinated listening to it to
a fight so
and it's interesting too because it's
just the audio not so you're not looking
at their body language
um which can be completely misleading
and there was another podcast where they
talked about how judges make worse
decisions on whether or not somebody
deserves you know parole or to be
released on bail when they see the
person
in person versus if they're just
looking at the information on paper
so i think body language and those kinds
of things can be can actually be
misleading
um or we think that like by looking
somebody in the eye will know if they're
lying or not but the skilled liars are
able to
um bypass that or they
because
i'm jumping all over the place but one
of the things about sociopaths is
they're not going to have the same tell
so like if i was lying somebody would
know because
i'm like stressed out mortified i'm
probably doing all the things that we do
when we lie because it's stressful for
me whereas they don't
have those things so i think that
you know they could for example i think
that they could pass a lie detector test
they also don't have like a startle
response
so
the activity in their brain like if you
and i watched something
graphic and tragic on tv or watched
something happen like things would
happen in our brains that don't happen
in the brains of sociopaths so they
don't react to things in the same way
that
that we do again but that makes sense
keep assuming i'm not associated i
didn't say i'm not a sociopath this
assumption you keep making it's very
interesting
then why did i murder all those people
let's get back to the um
what were we talking about johnny depp
and amber heart so the audio that i
heard made me
without knowing anything else made me
very inclined to be
team johnny dapp
yeah based on that based just based on
that audio yeah well that's how the
people are feeling about this whole
interaction by the way i do think it's a
very healthy thing to do in a
relationship is to record each other for
months at a time
uh every time you fight that just seems
like a very um sarcasm i don't i don't
understand how that because they both
recorded each other
it it just it's okay i suppose you could
look back at all human relations and be
like this was ridiculous what was i
doing
but when you're in it you don't
right i wondered that too like who made
the recording and why and
um
and did they both know about it that it
was being recorded
sometimes they did sometimes they didn't
uh all i know is just the poetry
of johnny depp's speaking and
sort of um
movement about the whole thing it's
interesting it makes you wonder what's
real maybe this is whole
maybe maybe they're both in love and
this is like a a troll that they played
on the world i don't know
it makes me wonder what's real at all
like i
because there you have to remember their
actors too
yeah i don't think he would have filed
the lawsuit if not i mean i'm joking no
i know but but no i mean my point is um
yes yeah
if somebody was trying to make the
argument that like he's the abuser
and that he's lying and he's full of
[ __ ] it sort of doesn't make sense that
he would have
filed a lawsuit unless he's trying to
have this all
come out in the open
because he believes he's in the right
you know again i don't i have no idea i
agree with you i agree with you
as a fan of
love and human nature i appreciate the
fact that they went through this i know
it's probably extremely painful
but
it's it's fascinating to watch
human relationships be presented in such
raw way and it made me realize how rare
it is to get a glimpse like that
yeah and i think one of the reasons i
like that book confessions of a
sociopath also is
it's you know
female who's writing it and i think
um statistically men are more likely to
be sociopaths
maybe not i mean these are all
things where
a lot of times
there exist
statistics that
would be inherently hard to get
so who knows but
i think that people tend to think of
sociopaths more as men
and then which probably gives female
sociopaths the advantage and that people
are less likely to
um
like the elizabeth homes like people who
are really manipulative and really good
at it um
and and
part of
how they're able to succeed is that
people don't understand their motives or
people will assume that
people behave rationally even if
rationally means
it's like anthony strange's
you know it would have made more sense
if he had gotten all this money out of
me
and you know put it in an overseas
account and then ditched me and got on a
plane to mexico like everybody would
understand that more
whereas
you know the way
things happened and he dragged me around
the country and like what were we doing
in tennessee and then
why didn't like nothing really makes any
sense
but
and also all the things that he did
to me and had me do it was as if
all of those things together only make
sense if his primary goal
was to maximally destroy me and also
make it
like have me burn all my bridges and
make it so i'll never recover
and when you read a book like that you
understand that that's
that's what he wanted like that's his
life
it's like a game like what what do you
think it's about power and it's a game
do you think he understood the long-term
goals he has or was it the short-term
game of it that he enjoyed the ability
to destroy you well yeah it was the
short-term
game of it because control another human
yeah and also i think for him like
their motivations are just different so
you know he spent a year incarcerated
because he never got out on bail but
then he got out
um
he's out of prison now he got out before
i went in to serve my time which was
um particularly
you know
like psychologically i had to try really
hard not to be infuriated and
um
but anyway
so i think for him
you know the consequence of spending
time in jail sort of like an
inconvenience
you know it's like life is a game
and so he wouldn't feel
if you're not capable of being
emotionally hurt
then
you're
you know you have immense power because
you can go around and do things
and people can't hurt you it's like a
superpower and he did this for people
who are not familiar i guess he did this
to other women
yes
yes i think it was in the documentary
that
his i guess ex-wife
from somewhere else florida florida of
course florida
sorry
strong
strong words well it's just like when
there's the weirdest story about you
know people eating
tide pods and then doing crazy it's like
it's always in it's always in florida so
i feel like whenever crazy so to me it
makes sense that he would have spent
time in florida before and that's where
crazy in a good way
and i mean that on an insult on him i
also like she's an amazing person yes so
it's it's like it's him that i'm
making the like
florida is
not that weird
yes he he manipulated her as well lied
to her that kind of things
um well jumping around but one of the
things you said that was disturbingly
misleading is the ending of the
documentary and the the ending
has a phone call i think yeah of you and
anthony talking so high level let me ask
uh how many times have you talked
with anthony since you got
out of prison and what did you talk
about and why is that
quote misleading that uh uh segment of
audio misleading
my issue with it also was that it was
deliberately misleading which was
what was particularly
um infuriating about it infuriating
about it um
and then also there was
it was like there were thing
one major thing that was incorrect that
i think
helped allow people to make an incorrect
conclusion at the end was um
in the in the film it talks about i say
something about how my accountant made a
joke about if i married him he could
easily transfer me money without tax
consequences and then
the film has me saying something like
you know and then within 24 hours we
were married but that's like audio from
here and audio from here spliced
together so they made it seem
like they're like i married him because
it was like he could give me money and
that wasn't the case so you're
part mastermind of some kind of scheme
that involved
money transfer and you got married and
that kind of right or if nothing else i
had like i was trying to get money
that's why i married him so which which
is absurd because again you know
new york is full of legitimate people
with loads of money if i really wanted
to marry somebody for money in new york
it wouldn't be that hard to do
but anyway it was like it was just a
deliberate
making it seem like my intention was you
know to marry him for his fictitious
money
right um
okay so that's one and either way let's
go to that ending thing because because
we're on that sort of topic because
when you got out of prison
you know the what the film implies
is that
whatever there's a small aspect of your
mind that still wants to continue a
relationship with anthony yeah that's
not the case and
not just that but there's still
flirtation and that kind of
a body collide
like
we got the the world
like at our fingertips we're playing
so i mean one of the exciting things
about being
like a couple that's [ __ ] with the
world that's getting away with something
is that
there's all these powerful forces that
want to catch you
in a crime and you keep getting away
with it that's exciting
uh in some
[Music]
world it could be although
in this case
right and also i always have to keep
reminding people like get away with what
because i lost everything and
all these people lost other you know
people i cared about lost a lot
my mother lost a lot
but i lost everything too yeah your um
your restaurant
and all my dream
yeah my reputation my stuff
my home
you know
ending up with millions of dollars of
debt like it's not even like i lost it
all and then it's a clean slate it's
like i lost it all and now i have this
like giant
boulder of
or like this wobbly
unclear how to like yeah so when people
say
well sisyphus got a thing
away with something i'm always like got
away with what i know destroying my life
and ending up in debt because that's
it's not even like
you can't even sort of
point to like
as if i was trying to do something and
then oops that happened it's like
there's no nothing that logically makes
sense if somebody was trying to
um
uh decipher
my you know whatever motives i might
have had yeah you didn't walk away from
the explosion you were inside the
explosion
okay
but that said the movie implied and so i
mean it's interesting to ask
um not just
in
and clarifying the movie but just as a
human being
you're out of prison he's out of prison
there was
you know there was that
um toxic connection but it was there
and there was a depth to it so toxic
connections could be pretty deep
so
how what what was the conversation like
and how often have you talked with him
well we don't speak anymore um and
that call on at the end was even on g
chat recorded
was recorded on like i recorded the call
and gave it to them you know so i was
like deliberately recording him it's not
like i was caught on a hot mic like i
made that call it's part of the
documentary i reported him intentionally
i was trying to get him to repeat some
of like the kookier things he would say
about
like his meat suit or
some of the weird like
the things about
something not being real
the more like fantastical things i was
trying to get him to repeat those things
it was probably like a 40-minute call
which i mean it's actually on my phone i
still have it i haven't gone back to
listen to it but you ever think of
publishing that whole thing oh yeah oh i
think about publishing everything my
entire journal oh you should publish
that call unedited just publish it that
would be fun no i want to publish like a
lot of stuff
he took all these videos of me also that
they used a couple of clips of and i
would yeah i mean i would they're also
on my phone i would publish them all i
would publish everything
in particular
um because should i release that with
your book skip
yeah
i probably i mean i've planned to do
that
eventually if all of that material would
be really useful to um
psychologists or people studying it so
to the extent that it would help other
people understand what happened
um which is still out there meaningful
yeah he's still out there doing weird
weird [ __ ]
with his clean slate
i get a little annoyed about that
he's got the clean slate well he didn't
have a
restaurant he didn't have a persona
does he have any public persona or no or
we don't know he got booted off of
twitter
we'll put him back on
is that a passive aggressive thing no
not at all i i find that whole
conversation really really interesting
um whether to put somebody like anthony
on back on twitter well no i think
because i used to always think like if
only
everybody had to identify as themselves
on twitter and you could have like a
parody account yeah or like like leon
has an account but it's very clear that
it's me behind it or sometimes there's
like you know devin nunes cow like so
people have parody accounts but but if
we could identify who it is
then
um
a lot of why did he get booted off of
twitter
i don't know but i used to so in the
last few years i would periodically
probably like once a month maybe more i
would like look at his twitter just to
kind of see like well where is he and
um
you know like just to see like what is
he up to
and um
and i figured out i could tell from the
photographs that he'd moved to
california and i think he might have
told me one of the last times i spoke to
him
that he was going to move to california
but
um
and then i also
screen grabbed a lot of stuff that he
put on twitter and he put these creepy
videos of himself on twitter at the
beginning of covid i screen grabbed
those um
just and then one day i went and like he
was you know account was suspended
and then i kept going back and it's like
been suspended ever since so he might
have started a new account and i don't i
don't know what it is
probably he's probably in california
you're saying
he is in california that's been
verified somebody who was gonna have to
interact with him in an official
capacity
was gonna go meet him and i said
and was nervous about it and i said
um
he's going to be really likable like
you're going to like him he's probably
going to like figure out what you're
interested in
talk sports talk whatever it is that he
figures out quickly that you're
interested in he's going to be really
nice he's going to seem like a nice guy
and that person later got back to me was
like you're exactly right yeah um so
yeah that's the that's the sociopath
thing right
yeah extremely careful but inside
relationship that's even more dangerous
like
so i think that
part of the reason i spoke to him was
entirely self-serving and strategic
after the fact
well even before i knew there was ever
going to be a documentary i spoke to him
and i and i knew how dangerous it was
because i knew that
in a situation like this you're supposed
to have no contact which makes sense and
i understand why which makes it extra
tragic when people have kids with a
sociopath or in a narcissistic abusive
relationship if you have kids then
you're tethered which is tragic
but
why are you supposed to avoid
conversations because you you can get
pulled right back so they have no
contact yeah because they'll
continue
abuse or they'll you'll be
vulnerable to them being able to pull
you back in
so i knew that to be the case um
but why was it self-serving why did you
talk to him anyway
because he was getting out
um he was gonna be out free out in the
open while i was gonna be locked up at
rikers for three and a half months
and the one thing
that
you know if his motivation was to
destroy me
then what what else could he do to
really like you know hammer that last
nail in the coffin yeah
that would be leon
and
so he would have known that leon would
be staying with my mother
you know he knows where he spent a lot
of time at her house he knows where she
lives it would be super easy for him to
just drive up there
you know wait
for her to let him out
and then you know he'd because out in
the country
he can be off leash and all he'd have to
do is kind of whistle call him over and
he could take him away and do whatever
so i was completely
like gripped with that fear
so not fear for yourself but fear for
leon
well i was gonna be
at least safe from him but i was
gonna be locked away so
oh oh yeah yeah rikers yeah sure so i
got it got it got it
i would be powerless to do anything and
he would be have free reign to go
destroy me further by um
you know taking or hurting leon
um
and then when he got out
i
still um i had unfollowed him from my
own account but
leon had never unfollowed him so i i was
looking at i know
i was looking at his um
at his account i just love can i just
say because uh because joe has a um
his he hasn't account for his dog too i
just love when people do that it's so
great because i actually pretend
in my mind for some reason i do think
leon has an account like i don't
you forget that there's a human behind
it you're like oh okay cool yeah
i know i love it when people do that
anyway so continue so leon didn't
unfollow him and what what
so
i was able to go back and look at his
twitter and um
he
he somehow he quickly got a phone but he
very quickly started tweeting right
after he got out yeah and um
and i was kind of like fascinated
because i didn't know
what to expect or what he was going to
be saying and and um
and then he started saying things that i
could tell were directed at me you know
like little things that only i would
know
um you know like random things like
things that were like the equivalent of
like an inside joke that you have just
so he was
posting things like that
and um
there's so many things going on at once
so another thing that would have in a
twisted but i think understandable way
in sort of a sick way that i was fully
aware of
is that
here i am having gone through this
completely like messed up thing that now
i'm in trouble for everybody's looking
at and nobody understands
right
and so there was this unfortunate
situation of the only person who
understands
what
i went through
is the person who put me through it yeah
right so
so is it were you also just a little bit
seeking closure of some kind
probably a lot but also with the
awareness that i probably wasn't gonna
get it you know and i mean i
i know for a fact i would never get it
in the same way that
which is why
um
which is why i was able to later on
like in the context of recording those
calls
i was able to talk to him
in this detached way
because i know he doesn't give a [ __ ]
that like he doesn't give any shits
about what he did to my mother or me or
anybody or anything just doesn't care so
he's certainly not going to care if i
you know he's never going to say like
i'm sorry or
i did a bad thing or
or like he's not gonna be affected if
like if i yelled and screamed at him
that would just be frustrating for me
and he would actually probably be
gratified by that
so
so that that gave you uh that empowered
you in being
cold and sort of yes and i had a distant
prior experience
where i had to do the same thing where
like if you're if you're able to
be very
cold and not allow somebody to push your
buttons
then you're taking away their power and
then that feels empowering or feels like
we're claiming a little bit of your
power so
in my talking to him i always had a
reason you know like there was always
like i didn't want him to hurt leon or
i wanted information or i wanted to know
where he was i'd rather let him think
that
you know maybe he could still manipulate
me one day or whatever it was like safer
to keep
that there than to not know where he was
and if i was gonna like
be walking leon and turn the corner and
he's standing there and you know like it
like if there's a crazy murderer out on
the loose you'd rather know where they
are than have no i have no idea
so there are a lot of different reasons
um why does it upset you
why was it wrong to have that audio clip
at the end of the documentary like what
did it uh well because it implied all
kinds of things that were completely not
true and it also just didn't make sense
and it confused people and
um so
so for people who haven't watched that
spoiler alert as they play the the clip
of
um sorry i don't even remember what was
said but it was kind of
that last what we spoke about yeah what
was the what was that i only watched
like i still haven't watched it i only
watched the film once yeah while
you know people were looking at me for
my reaction and i was crying and it was
really weird and strange and surreal and
i haven't gone back to watch it again i
feel like i'm just gonna get more
annoyed
but i i will eventually but
and when i
when the ending happened i immediately
blurted out like i hate that i hate that
ending but i sort of assumed
a lot of people saw it for what it was
they saw that it was like
the director doing a weird thing and
that it was kind of just weird and off
and like that doesn't make sense yeah it
seemed blue but so it was basically you
joking around like flirting almost it
made it seem like
as if we're still friendly yeah um and
there's more to come it's almost like
there's going to be
a um
bad vegan too
right or
yeah and then also i mean it made it
seem like
you know
if i was laughing with him that i
don't take anything seriously you know
that i don't take what happened
seriously or yeah but it's like a
feeling of remorse exactly
yeah and they
after that he goes the credits with the
wild world
which is a great song
yes oh baby it's a wild world
i never got to hear that because the
version i watched didn't have the end
credits but i knew that they used that
song at the end um
and uh paid a lot for it
yeah yeah i was like oh why you got this
song
did you ever say what was the darkest
thing
about yourself that you discovered from
the book yes oh
we we did we no we took
yeah about the g chats and i think um
it was
i guess it was trying to understand how
i was able to be sarcastic and make
jokes at his expense
dirt while all that stuff was going on
ah
so what's that that's that have you
figured out
what that means about you
no no it just was interesting to look at
and
also i think um
you know i've
i have a tendency i have a tendency
sometimes to be sort of like
jokingly
hyperbolic or sarcastic and it's gotten
me into trouble
one
one time it i got
locked up in the
harlem psych ward for a day because of
my hyperbole and sarcasm and like
until the story lost in translation
errors
that's that's a heck of a loss in
translation error yeah
did you did you say something funny to a
therapist it was um yeah i mean i was
sort of making jokes about
how bad i was feeling but in a
hyperbolic way and so then suddenly
somebody told somebody
and then the loss in translation and
then they were worried that i might kill
myself
and then did a wellness check and then
tried to call me and i was in the shower
so i didn't answer the phone
so then
somebody called the police to do a
wellness check on me
um things just escalated and then uh not
knowing that
um
if i had handled it the right if i had
immediately
um
if i'd sort of understood what was going
on and handled it the right way
immediately i probably could have gotten
out of it but they err on the side of
taking you to the hospital no matter
what makes a lot of sense and i didn't
know that and it also um so you really
leaned into the joke by going to the
hospital
i didn't
it's sort of one of those situations
that was both comical and tragic because
and would actually make a really good
um
it's weird how i do this sometimes like
it would make a really good scene in a
and a filmed version who would play you
in the film
uh i don't know
there is a thing being made that's
sharon
because um
because
have you cast the scene yet
no
but
there's a thing being made that i have
nothing to do with which is frustrating
and weird a film about you about
it's like somebody's making a
fictionalized drama
and it's frustrating because
for all kinds of obvious reasons it's
like
annoying and it can go anyway it could
go anywhere you could be like the bad
guy inevitably they'll get a bajillion
things wrong
and they're also a bunch of people like
profiting off of it and like thanks guys
you know so it's infuriating for all
kinds of
reasons do you know who's playing who
are the
actors no i don't even like i just don't
like all i'll inevitably know but i
don't really want to know the whole
thing is just annoying and also
i've always people ask me this all the
time and i always thought
um because of the way
everything that happened was such a kind
of a slow build and there was so much
nuance and it's
it's kind of really hard to understand
that it could only really be done well
in like a breaking bad type of series
long
like a long series where like you would
be taken through these kind of
gut-wrenching
icky
slow build things
and then peop that would make it all
make sense like that
if it was done that way it could be done
accurately
but
the reason why i think um
so i made these stupid jokes and then
somebody did a wellness check and um
or have you ever asked the police to do
it well but when they knocked on my door
and came in it was like a repeat of
getting arrested so i sort of weirdly
flashed back to that and then burst into
tears which isn't the appropriate
response if you're trying to
um
diffuse a
if you're trying to discourage the
people coming to do the wellness check
from taking you to the hospital starting
to cry is not the good the right
reaction well the thing is i mean
there is
it's funny but it could be also through
the joke
that
the joke the best jokes are grounded in
truth and pain in this case pain
yeah right so there you go
um have you ever
if i may ask
considered suicide
yes
one
well
i'm kind of a wimp so i you know i'm
afraid of all of the gruesome ways but
um
one of the things i remember doing
is
sort of hoarding medications
which i had
when um
around the time and before he took me
away
because i wanted like i wanted to i
wanted the safety of a like an out
um
and
but around that time so when it when
anthony went that's the the road trip
right before the road trip from hell you
were around that time yeah sporting
medication and like i yeah
like if i could get my hands on any sort
of weird medication i would
i would kind of hold on to it
um
and
to all the chaos but i think i knew that
it would be hard to do it that way
but i didn't thought about it but i
never
um
in that really tough time
you know you're thinking about
you're thinking about taking your own
life
what gave you hope
what gave you sort of because
the business
the the restaurant that you give so much
of yourself to is lost
you're lying to everybody
you're in the hole financially
you're being
psychologically trapped manipulated go
kill myself now
well you're still there
um please don't see i made a joke about
it like that's there you go
um but it's always there
it's the uh
albert camus you know says
you basically always have to
be
uh aggressively looking for a reason to
live
otherwise
what's the point
yeah otherwise it's easy to to go the
other way
because why live is a very good question
um but anyways it's by way of hope by
way you know it's it's a dark time
that's the dark time
if you could sort of look back what
um we'll give you just strength
i think that just
you know just having like a sort of
relentless optimism
um and i think too that
sometimes people assume that
suicide is the result of circumstances
which may be in maybe in some cases it
is but i think one of the things that
that book explains well is that very
often it doesn't have anything to do
with circumstances it's just the
the pain
which book
the the darkness visible
um you know because people like to cry
so when somebody commits suicide people
will very often criticize them like it
was a selfish act if they have a family
which most people do but especially if
they have kids and i think that
um
yeah everybody's quick to sort of call
the person who killed themselves selfish
and um
it's i think that the type of pain that
one is experiencing that leads to that
is something that most people and i
don't like people don't understand
but it's not a selfish thing it's just
like quite literally becomes intolerable
from what i understand
and it can hit you it could be slow it
could be fast
yes that pain
yes so
i think because
for me it was more just my circumstances
were so
crappy but also i had an awareness that
you know even in rikers i knew how
wildly lucky
i was to
have you know
family a support system
you know
opportunities in like i'll always be
okay one way or another
um
so
i felt
lucky that i i have that but
uh you know
also i want you know the shame of
everything that happened and
you know will i ever be able to crawl
out from under it
and rebuild something i don't know
um
so there were certainly times where
especially when i would learn something
new like reading the emails between
mr fox my mother i just wanted a
so he i wanted like a meteor to hit
my particular spot on the earth
right then and there just because it was
he was manipulating your mom too because
your mom loved you and was willing to
give money yeah
yeah and it was really grotesque and so
and i feel like it's my fault
um what's your mom say about this whole
situation now looking back
we don't talk about it as much as one
would think that we
would
um
because i feel sickening because i feel
like it's my fault and i think she also
feels sick over it and so we don't talk
about it as much as one might think
sometimes i've had to ask questions in
the process of writing the book
and then there are other things where
like i could ask the questions but i
just don't want to because i don't want
to put her through that or
you know it's not really
necessary to ask the questions but there
are things that i'm sort of curious
about
um
but
when you
went on that road trip from hell
what was what was that like where'd you
guys go first vegas
so you drove from new york
where
it was a series of stops at like hotel
motel type places because i did a
similar road trip but from boston i
drove across the united states
with no destination i had always wanted
to do that and now again i feel like
it's one of those things that sort of
like ruined for me because
a lot of you can always reclaim it
yeah i could but now
yeah
i did think about like how one day if i
did some sort of a book tour or
something that i imagine this but leon
and i in a car
it has to be different than uh
uh man
book tours
they if not if you're not careful can
suck the soul
out of a human being i think you have to
do like a hunter s thompson style um
book tour where you miss a bunch of the
dates because you got too drunk the
night before but anyway or i just what i
worry about is that i just would
be feeling terrible
in some way and not be
up for it
or for the trip or for off the speaking
because for like a certain type of
appearance i think i'm always afraid of
that
in um
committing to things like if it involved
going to a big public event yeah i think
you have to be very careful like podcast
is an interesting one i'm always
surprised that people just
jump on podcasts they haven't really
listened to
and just just do a lot a lot of podcasts
that kind of book tour
first of all financially it doesn't make
any sense
like especially going on a small podcast
like what's the benefit like really you
want to go on just a couple of big
podcasts that you're actually a fan of
it's really really really important
people don't
um
like they don't understand the power i
mean maybe you just don't understand
podcasting but me as a fan of podcasts
is like the biggest thing i love
listening to is
when a guest is a fan they understand
that the culture the style the sound the
feel the unders of the podcast they
understand the other person
they feel the pain the hopes of the
other person the the the the weird like
uh quirks of the other person
makes for much better listening
and ultimately the appearance itself is
not just enough to sell the book you
have to you're selling yourself as a
human being and that requires having
chemistry and all those kinds of things
yeah i agree
and podcast appearance is exhausting
like you're giving a lot of yourself
it's intimate it's deep like i don't
know
anyway
road trip you don't remember the motels
in the hotels along the way
well there are a lot of things where
like i'll remember things that happened
but i don't remember where it was
he just drove without a destination
really
i assume he must have known ahead of
time but he made it seem like like oh
funny we ended up in vegas
funny how that happened but it now when
i see all the places that we stopped
they were all places with um where there
were casinos
so there's a lot more casinos around the
country than i knew
um
and there
uh so
so he had a gambling addiction
yes but i think that
it's not a so i think that regular
people have gambling addictions and it's
a horrible tragic thing and can destroy
their lives and i you know i know people
who've like it regular people can have a
gam
a gambling addiction which is explained
in the way that addictions are explained
um for him i don't think it was so much
an addiction as
um
like a thrill seeking because
he could win money lose money and he
didn't really care whereas
somebody who has an actual addiction and
then all
normal people with normal human emotions
you know would either be elated
and relieved or
devastated
um
to lose a lot of money and for him it it
it didn't really care it was more again
i think it was more just like a game
like what what were you what was going
through your mind here like would you be
on the run did you feel like you were on
the run
no did you know you were on the run
no so i didn't know that um i mean the
other thing is the
the restaurant was operating
and he took me away and then like
people weren't paid and it all sort of
fell apart and you weren't checking your
texts or any any of that
no and then he had my phone
and my email
um i did
later on get
later on i got a brand new phone with
like a
an empty phone with no existing numbers
in it or whatnot
and so that he and i could communicate
when
i you know
i was
went to the grocery store or something
like that what was the uh what was the
reason he had the phone like what was
the narrative the story that he he was
taking over your phone
was it i mean
like how how did you allow that to
happen or maybe a better way to ask us
how did he make that happen
well i was conditioned to it before
because before he was always checking my
phone which
was
wildly infuriating and i feel like um
like
you fixed it by giving him the phone
well i mean the conditions were
different later on but in some sense i
didn't want my phone because everything
like i was in a state of shock and it
was just like
take it fine like i give up like i guess
i'd given up
and and so
yeah i'd given up so there was no like i
wasn't going to fight back on anything
um
before when he would take my phone and
look through it it was it was
infuriating
and he sort of
forced me to get used to it
and this is again something that like
people have been in cults would
understand because it's like they
condition you to not
react negatively to things that you
would normally react negatively to
um
and like if i was in a relationship like
if somebody
i would never ever look in somebody's
phone
and
and if somebody did that to me i would
be like goodbye
um so
i'm pretty sensitive about that
and um
so it was very infuriating when he would
take my phone and look at it and it it
got to the point where
not only did i feel like everything i
you know said or wrote or
emailed digitally or whatnot
would be read but he he got me to the
point of feeling like i was being
watched all the time
in a
non-explainable way
yeah what were some of the
you didn't mention them some of the
documentary touches on some of them
what are some of the fantastical stories
so he mentioned that
he might help make uh leon a more
immortal
what
all of that was always really vague i
mean intentionally like a lot of what he
talked about was always very vague
but
a lot of that stuff was very vague and
and again like but convincing slowly
over time and a lot of those things too
are things that
um
[Music]
you know conveniently
you kind of can't disprove
so it's almost like you know people
believe in god or religious people
believe certain things
um and so
one could argue why
is it that much crazier for me to have
been open to the idea that
you know maybe leon
maybe we do live forever
in some way when so a lot of religious
people have similar beliefs so one of
the other thing is he was uh
what um maybe you can correct me but
reincarnated or something like that
or
he acted like he
had lived many lifetimes and had all
kinds of
wisdom from having
lived all these prior lifetimes
and being
aware of it so was that and it was vague
but it was somehow believable or is it
just like part of the charm
like what
how do you
how do you not call [ __ ]
i know uh we're not not necessarily
[ __ ] i i understand when you're
smitten in whatever way
but like one a little more details
proof i suppose it's easy to just
you know like um
put it off for later
assume that more details will come later
right
i think he's a mentalist or an
illusionist named darren brown
and it was
on a joe rogan podcast i think joe
interviewed darren brown
um
i think sam harris interviewed him i got
really intrigued and then i was looking
for other podcasts or maybe joe
interviewed him
like right after
i may have gone looking for it but
anyway it was in the it was in the
conversation with joe where darren
explains um he's somebody i would love
to to meet
a mentalist an illusionist because they
understand a lot of the ways in which
the mind can be manipulated so i feel
like they would if they
looked at everything about my situation
they would be able to understand better
how
he was able to get me to
believe things or go along with things
or
because darren brown is pretty
fascinating what he does and he's really
seems like a very kind person and he's
very open about it and um when he was
talking to joe he said this thing
that and i use this quote in my book
um
and again i'm paraphrasing because i
don't have in front of me but it's like
he says something about how um
we want to believe the lie
because we'd rather believe
that it's something amazing than just
that ugly and pathetic a lie
[Music]
and i
whatever he said was said in a much
better way but the point is like that's
and so he was explaining it in the
context of the way that an illusionist
or whatever
they're called is able to to pull off
certain things
which is that they're sort of
you know somebody was about somebody who
was watching and watched them watch that
person um
sort of leverage people's tendency to
want to believe that something amazing
and cool is about to happen versus like
this is just a really ugly pathetic lie
so i think that a lot of the things
um
that
that mr fox that that he put forward um
i couldn't understand it from the
perspective of it being a lie because it
just seemed too weird and crazy so i
think that this happens sometimes where
um you believe somebody because
it seems so weird that they would
lie about it i think that somebody has
or it's been said sometimes that like
the more fantastical the lie the more
believable it is because you don't you
don't believe that somebody would tell
that lie
and i think um
something also that mr fox people like
him are capable of doing is going out
and lying
in very brazen ways that normal people
would be terrified to do
so that kind of also makes it more
believable yeah so if somebody could go
out on a world stage and lie
and not
kind of
feel weird about that or
even knowing that it's a lie that can be
pointed out as being a lie um
and then there's also the the
layer of to what extent is this person
in some way also delusional themselves
and sort of believing their lies because
people have asked me that and i've
wondered the same thing to what extent
did he believe some of the stuff he was
saying and i think probably
there was some
sort of
delusional aspect almost like he was
sort of halfway aware of playing his own
sort of virtual reality game you know
like
like he was in some kind of metaverse in
his brain so you think he believed some
of the things he was saying
in some way yeah
what uh or he wanted to you know because
he wanted to be his own like he wanted
to be a superhero you know he never
built anything or created anything or
accomplished anything in his life
yet
you know so so in his own brain if he
could turn himself into like a movie
superhero it's a nice shortcut
yeah what about the navy seal thing did
that ever
get resolved
you know the
the lie that he he you know he said that
he's a navy seal
i don't remember i don't know if he said
he was a navy seal or that he implied
that he like worked with the cia or then
it was like he worked with black ops
that you know is by definition under the
radar right so i mean that's obviously a
huge red flag now going forward is like
if somebody
first of all if somebody tells you that
information pretty quickly that's itself
a red flag but
i mean
all right cross i'm you cross that off
my list of pick-up lines
um
but you know conveniently if he
say
in some world he actually did work for
like black water or one of those places
or
yeah there i wouldn't be able to just
call someplace and verify it um
anyway yeah so i think that
in some psychological way that i don't
understand he probably did in some way
halfway exists in this world where he
was this
um
you know like fighter and he would say
things like it's because of people like
me that people like you can sleep at
night which is probably a line out of a
movie that i've never seen i feel like a
lot of things great that's a great
that's funny
that is a good the um who said that
that's a really that's uh is that really
a line out of a movie it's not a movie
it's uh
you know what would happen at rikers is
when these things would happen where one
of us couldn't think of something and
you're like oh who was that actor in
that movie and that thing
no and so what we'd do is like somebody
would be on the phone and you'd be like
hey
who are you talking to can you ask them
to look up on their phone like so we'd
ask people on the phone or somebody
would go make a call and
you know you'd have to call somebody and
ask them to google
the cast of a movie or something like
that i think you would find jail don't
ever get arrested or try not to but i
think you would find jail fascinating oh
i always wanted to go to jail
prison because uh
there's a lot of elements to it and i'll
ask you questions about it but i feel
like i can get a lot of reading done
i got a ton of reading done yes yeah yes
i don't remember now people attribute
this to george orwell but they're not
sure if george orwell ever said it but
it's something like there's a lot of
different variations
but we sleep safely at night because
rough men stand ready to visit violence
on those who would harm us
and there's a lot of variations of this
but basically we depend our entire
society depends on
bad [ __ ] who are willing to
fight
to protect our freedoms to protect our
well-being
and um
one of the things about the united
states is because we're surrounded by
water we don't get to see the violence
that's required
in part to protect the sovereignty of
nations
uh you mentioned
that i would uh not to go to prison but
that i
may enjoy my time there let me ask you
uh not the i mean by the way i love
prison movies you would find it
fascinating i don't because it's like
still kind of too soon
but well how was your time you spent
three and a half
months
at rigers how was that how was your
experience in prison
how's the food from a chef perspective
not good but rikers was
um
when i got to write because i so
i was arrested i spent i think about 10
days in a tennessee small town tennessee
jail
um
oh pigeon forge is also the weirdest
place on earth is it a town yes that's
the town where i was arrested why is it
so weird um
in the film they i told them i told them
you have to go to pigeon forge you have
to go there you have to go there and i i
think i was pushing them because it was
gonna potentially be
the end of the season
it's like a summer time or it's a
tourist destination
and it's so bizarre and weird and trippy
that
um
it doesn't even seem real seems like a
carnival is happening there non-stop
exactly it's it's car i think i say that
in my intro that it's carnival-esque and
trippy and weird
is there a lot of clowns walking around
or not necessarily clowns but there is a
video on youtube that i
cause i got to the chapter where we
arrive in pigeon forge and i'll never
forget although i have forgotten but i
remember being
like weirdly
like felt like we were had entered a
different universe driving down this
strip and just looking at everything on
either side and i'm wishing that i could
remember in more detail like the names
of the places or what was there because
i wanted to describe it um in this
chapter and i was like i wish somebody i
wish there was like a video of somebody
going down the street kind of showing
what's on one side and then the other
side and i was like
there probably is and there is on
youtube like i found it and i watched
the whole thing how does this come up
from prison exactly
um picture
oh okay
so that's the town that i went to jail
and
all right in tennessee right so what was
that like
the food there
and some of the conditions
the food
made when i got to
um that i was extradited and transferred
to rikers and when i got to rikers i
felt like it was like the four seasons
in comparison wow so um and i i really
kind of appreciated a lot of things
about
about new york when i got when i got to
rikers even though there are a lot of
things that are very scary about it
where's uh right located is it close to
new york city
yes and in a very
kind of
almost
poetically interesting way
the the dorm room where i was when i was
there for the three and a half months
was one of the ones that faced manhattan
so i could go across the room and look
out the window and see the whole
manhattan skyline
which was i remember being
shocked by
the cost
per prisoner per year
yes
that uh new york pays it's like 400 500
000 or something
i didn't think it was that much i
thought i wrote it down but either way
it is no i mean it it
elevated uh during covid which is
fascinating to that the number i just
said
yeah
during covet i felt sick to my stomach
thinking about people stuck there and
again so rikers isn't like a long-term
prison it's most of the people at rikers
are awaiting
trial
and they've been arrested but not
convicted and then if you're convicted
and you're sentenced to less than a year
then you put on a different color
uniform and you go upstairs to different
dorms
if you're convicted and sentenced to
more than a year you're sent to one of
the upstate prisons
so most of the people at rikers are
there in transition they've been
arrested but not
they've been arrested but not
convicted or awaiting trial so you could
be
perfectly innocent
and you're stuck there and that happens
to a lot of people
or you could be arrested
over some kind of
comparatively petty thing or non-violent
thing
and and stuck there because you don't
have as little as 500 to pay
bail which is completely
messed up and unjust
and i think most people most reasonable
people agree that it's unjust
but it's different when you're there and
you see those people and you see
um kind of the anguish
and whether i mean i have no idea if
they're guilty of what i mean
i usually
don't know what people are there for
what the situation is but you watch
the sort of
help helplessness set in um
because you're kind of powerless there
you have very little contact with the
outside world you have these limited
phone calls
and so
for people who had kids in a job and an
apartment it's like one by one those
things are lost or their
kids are now being looked after by their
abusive ex-husband or something like
that and so watching that is just
gut-wrenching and then also
knowing that
the only reason they're unable to get
out is because of you know a thousand
dollars two thousand dollars in some
cases five hundred dollars there were
people um
so there's all of these tragic cases but
then there was also
while i was there i mean if i'd had any
money i would have been wanting to bail
people out left and right and then in
some cases i think there was a woman
there snored really loud and her bail
was five hundred dollars and i was like
i wish i had i wanna bail out she just
wanted to bail her out so
um because i'm pretty sensitive to
sounds and being in a room with 50
people inevitably
so you're in a room with a large number
of people yeah there are um
there are areas there with cells but a
lot of the areas there are
um
rooms with
50 beds so and they're about three feet
apart from each other so
during covid there was certainly no
social distancing
um
and that just felt kind of
sickening especially because
so many people are there for
non-violent things or drug addiction
related or mental health issues
um part of that you personally just
having spent that time there for
three and a half months how did that
change you
like what
did that have an effect on your mind
on my mind personally i think i was
i was
surprised
at how
well i adapted and then how i was able
to um and then i think i sort of took it
a next level when one of the books
somebody sent me was um
the untethered soul by michael singer
and it's very much about like observing
your mind and um
that kind of
helped take it to next level so was this
like a meditation retreat for you
well it's like
it'd be like trying to meditate in the
middle of a circus or
in crazy circumstances because you're
never alone
there's nowhere to be alone and there's
always talking there's noises there's
fighting noises chaos um did you feel in
danger
yes
but
um
i i never i never felt terrified there
um
you know one of my friends the bathroom
is the scary place because they don't
have cameras in the
um
in the bathroom so that's sort of a
one has to watch out there and i did one
of my friends who i
one of the people i was friends with
there she did get
um beat up a bit in the bathroom
one day
a lot of weird [ __ ] happened in the
bathroom
um but it was
from a if you're interested in human
behavior and psychology and
it's it can be fascinating to kind of
sit there and watch they're saying like
you might enjoy prison for that
perspective like just you get to watch
human nature it's
um
like at the
i don't want to say that it's worse but
like the full variety that it can
uh
take right and there was a lot of beauty
there as well i mean was there love
people being um
well again depends on the definition of
love but
people being you know incredibly
generous and kind to each other um
um sometimes people singing at
night um
there was just a lot of
and then there was a lot of you know
hilarious stuff it's just it's all there
there's like those tragic things
um
you know interesting things
a lot of people with mental health
issues which is um can be
difficult
to witness so very different experience
i should
ask you this but
um
somebody that's currently in prison
galen maxwell
i believe she spent
approximately 500 days in isolation
so
it's a very difficult different prison
experience
but what do you think about her case
what do you think about her and jeffrey
epstein
she
so
her brother her family
she says
that she's a victim
not the monster
i think this is an especially
fascinating case because um
and i've i have
listened to podcasts about the you know
the epstein situation
um
and there was one that was more focused
on her by vicki ward that i would
definitely listen to
um
vicki ward
is a journalist i think she'd written an
article about jeffrey epstein for vanity
fair so she got to know jeffrey epstein
and then she knew colleen maxwell um
from being sort of part of the
social circle in which they would have
overlapped have you by the way ever met
them since this new york
do you remember meeting this
you know uh
jeffrey or
or gillian
no i never met them but they're also
very much like this sort of upper east
side crowd um i did meet harvey
weinstein once that made me have all
kinds of interesting thoughts later
at the restaurant or elsewhere no it was
weird it was out on the street
and we had this really strange
interaction
and
knowing what i know now
it was eerie and
and also like had he contacted me after
that
and made it seem like he could have done
something for me like would i have
been
you know say he said oh i'm gonna
finance your whole expansion or
something and like come to my you know
come meet me at this hotel and then i go
to that hotel and then he's like come up
to the room and then i would have been
like uh
and you're wondering whether you would
have done it
yes and sadly i think i would have and
so i felt a lot of
compassion for
um
those who
you know didn't
yell at him and leave or didn't storm
out
and because i think
what happens in those situations
is um
you know there's all kinds of
uncertainty in the moment and you sort
of freeze and then you'll if
i'm probably one of those people that
would
sit there and somehow in the moment
without clarity
just instinctively feel like somehow i
must have done something wrong and it's
my fault and and like i led him on and
or just being afraid and then and then
you don't know how to deal with it and
so you freeze
um
so i think that
you know if you're somebody that
maybe was raised differently or you have
a lot of self-confidence or
um you might have
reacted differently and kind of
pushed them away and stormed out
um
but i am probably not one of those
people
but i did not ever meet jeffrey epstein
but he seems very straightforwardly um
you know just a classic the way he was
able to charm people the way he
could step into these roles um
you know i think he was teaching at
dalton and then
just kind of the way he would get
himself into the
the academic crowd within harvard and i
think also mit right he sort of
so he's playing a role but he's doing it
so well that he fools all these people
and what and the things that people
would
in hindsight say about him
are just the same things that people say
about it's like you hear the same things
over and over again you hear the same
thing said about those people who were
taken in by elizabeth holmes is that
they were like
it was as if he was under a spell it was
as if i was under a spell
is something you hear a lot and so it's
like they have this
powerful charm that's almost over it's
overwhelming in that they overwhelm your
better judgment or they overwhelm your
like normal
otherwise normally functioning capacity
for
rational thought and they sort of
overwhelm that with their charm so
you know when you look at i think it was
like james mattis invested a bunch of
money with elizabeth holmes and
all these people were involved with her
and nobody really did their due
diligence where they just sort of
trusted her
and jeffrey epstein
i think it's still unclear where he got
all of his money
but the guy
wexner
les wexner
who had you know
an enormous amount of money and somehow
very quickly turned over management of
it to jeffrey epstein and so people
wonder like why would he do that that's
insane
and and and then other people have
commented
about that relationship like it was as
if he was under jeffrey's spell you know
observers would say i couldn't
understand it it was as if he was under
his spell and so somebody observing
me and mr fox could have possibly said
the same thing about me
but it's a bit different because it
wasn't all charm i think
um epstein used his charm and then was
probably very very very crafty and
getting um another thing that people
like him do and cults do also is to get
um
is to get you somehow compromised
because then they've got you
so i think
some kind of
usually sex related
yeah and with epstein certainly you know
he was known to have cameras everywhere
and so if he got any of these people on
camera doing something compromising and
all very powerful people
then he's got them
um and i think he was also very smart to
do that to target people of both parties
so that politically
that he was able to maintain his power
like no matter
like
nobody wanted him to be totally exposed
because then
people
a lot of people would be exposed um by
the way that part you know
that's all kind of
conspiracy right
right we don't know that
i
so a lot of people believe that and
you know i tend to kind of naturally
believe that because that makes sense
but it's also possible that
straight up with charisma
i mean he did record people and there
were recordings so
i listened to an interview with a woman
who i mean was a girl back then maybe
she was 15 or 16 back then
um
and subsequently
years later
was able to see some of the video of
i mean i think it's a verifiable thing
that there were video cameras all over
his house yeah the degree to which it
was used
right we don't know that
and um
to the degree of how many people were
involved and so on there's all kinds of
conspiracies around the man but the
question about
her
her galen
so
i only know what i know from the inputs
which are
the vicky ward
it was it's a pod it's one of the
podcasts it's a narrative podcast so
it's like a
um
it's like an audio kind of a documentary
or journalistic piece that she did and
put out
i thought it was really really well done
i think it's called chasing galen
um and i listened to that whole thing
i didn't intend to listen to it all
in one stretch that's how you know it's
good i mean it was like a weekend and i
basically was
you know cleaning and doing other things
and walking leon and listening to it and
i got through it pretty quickly but i
got really fascinated by it because um
i don't i don't know but i think
i feel
like i find the whole situation
gut-wrenching because i think
jeffrey epstein is a straight-up like
straight-up
sociopath like
no question
with her
everybody's calling her
evil and
for her to have enabled and done a lot
of the things that she did
could potentially require
one might say that it could require a
lack of empathy to be able to do those
things
knowingly
um
but at the same time
i think
the the information that was conveyed in
the vicki ward
piece
was fascinating to me because it's clear
that at the very least it's like it's
like all of these things could be true
she could maybe be
not enough of a good person to have you
know horribly victimized these young
girls and destroy their lives but she
could have all
i feel like i'm going to get bashed for
saying this but she could have in some
way have
not quite known what she was doing or
been a bit out of her mind
i'm just saying people i i would hope
that people would be open to that's
to exploring that as a possibility well
her family and friends are making that
case
they're they're painting
a
broad picture of who she is as a human
being and
showing that she couldn't have done any
of those things without being
like
systematically manipulated
that's their right what i listened to
in that podcast about
her relationship with her father
the
how her father died um
her things about her childhood and then
epstein coming into her life and
basically kind of pushing all those
buttons and becoming like the father
figure and so she would be in a position
of kind of always wanting his approval
and
um
and just the way that
things that are described about the way
that she
um
like was so subservient to him
in this kind of astonishing way
that seems really weird and abnormal
and yet i think she had a lot of
money and connections and i think she
lost the money but had all the
connections either way there was a lot
that a ton that epstein gained via his
relationship with her like a ton
so
it makes sense that he would have
manipulated her he manipulates everybody
so he
without question i think one could argue
he definitely manipulated her and again
i want to be like careful not to be
saying like that's an excuse for what
she did
i just think that
that's one possibility it's important to
like
explore these things and be open to them
as opposed to just
like broad brush painting her as a
horrible person i mean
because people could say that based on
things they've
read or things that i did that like i'm
a horrible person and it's very it's com
very different because what she did
involved
um
you know young girls whose lives were
destroyed
um
but i think that
people
could be a bit open to understanding how
somebody could be manipulated
there's a there's a psychologist that
i'm
friends with that i got to know
after i watched him on um
leah remini's
show so leah remini is the actress who
was in scientology got out and has
really been speaking out about it and
trying to expose um
what they're all about and how
diabolical that organization is and a
lot of people are exposing them and um
you know
doing this type of work and so she had
this guy on her show who was in the
moonies
and his name is um steve haasen
and
um so he was in a cult and then he got
out again by extreme circumstances he
got in a car accident almost died and
that's
what ended up getting him out of the
cult that he was in but really smart guy
um was targeted when he was young got
pulled into the moonies
but watching this interview of him on
her show
he said
he's talking about his experience and he
said if they had told me to kill
somebody i would have
and i
that in that moment made me cry but i
also felt
like
i understand that
and not that if mr fox had told me to
kill somebody i don't think i would have
but again i understand how it could get
to that point
so
that makes me feel like with her
like i would be curious what steve
hassan would think kind of analyzing the
entire situation
because it's hard to understand that
unless you've been in it and i
understand with him how he could have
said that if they had told me to kill
somebody i would have yeah that's pretty
intense i mean that's pretty extreme
and it's interesting how you can get
into it
how far you can go just one day at a
time like gradually
right just
like
the frog in the boiling water yeah so
fascinating i mean all of these cases
are fascinating like patty hearst that
whole story
well i'm just also
i
just uh it's already a while ago re-read
the rise and fall of the third reich
i've been reading a lot a lot about
hitler and gubbin
for a long time working on a series
about
hitler and the third reich because
it for me it's like returning
so much of my family was destroyed or
impacted by this time in history
that is somehow a way to find out
more about myself is going back to that
time have you ever thought about
inherited drama
this the sounds
not to mock people
but this sounds like a thing that
um like a woke thing
like like a woke thing yeah i don't mean
it that way at all but i get it because
sometimes
now when i say now i almost have to put
air quotes when i say something's
triggering because i feel like i'm using
a word that's now like
overused or
used in less serious so now when i say
something's triggering it's like
i use
yeah it's funny because good good words
get get uh taken up and then they get
people are overusing gaslighting yeah
and i worry that that would happen with
sociopathy like i think people need to
understand sociopathy i think it's
critical for humanity that people
understand it yeah so just because
you're being an [ __ ] doesn't doesn't
mean you're a sociopath exactly and i
feel like it's going to be this thing
where now everybody's going to start
calling everybody else's sociopath and
it's like oh you know and right now
everybody calls everything gas lighting
if somebody's lying it's not gas
lighting i have to talk we started
talking about i already forgot fluff is
it fluff it's fluff right fluff yeah
yeah okay so that was
that was great that's a new discovery
for me what um let's talk about food a
little bit if we can
you know what let's talk about
restaurants first what that's the
fascinating part of the story
before anything else
which is
opening
exceptionally successful restaurant in
nyc new york city what's that take what
does it take to
to open up from the very beginning from
the idea stage to the launching it both
the finances and the skill of actually
getting people super excited by it and
then running it all that chaos i mean to
me am i over romanticizing but it seems
like new york city is a really tough
place yes to to to launch a restaurant
in yes very well i think because it's
extremely competitive and the standards
are so high so i think that's why there
are
so many good restaurants
in new york because
if they're not good they're not going to
survive
so even like you could walk into what
looks like a hole in the wall and it's
going to have amazing food
um
that happens a lot so what was the menu
so was it a raw
was it vegan and raw from the beginning
yeah it was and raw means what now i'm
getting thrown back to all the
interviews i did when people ask me
these questions it was so long ago um
at the time i like being vegan
it
um so nothing was cooked over
roughly 118 degrees it was this very
like
the world of there were people who are
hardcore raw foodists and
um
and there's also people who are hardcore
vegans and i was never any of those
things
so i think what we did you weren't the
hardcore part or you
you weren't
but you
like
what parts of your life were you're a
vegan are you still a vegan do you eat
meat do you are you a vegetarian are you
raw
good question i don't
apply labels so none of those labels
would apply because it's male and female
that's i those i'm beyond those labels
myself as well
but i'm a
carnivore
most of the time
there you go it's the opposite of vegan
unfortunately but no judgment i think
that's a beautiful thing to be as vegan
likewise i think that it's people who
are very adamantly one way or the other
i think that
after all my
years in this world and
in this world in general
and also consuming an enormous amount of
um
inputs and podcasts about health like i
love listening to different points of
view so i love when like somebody's
arguing vegan and then somebody's
arguing carnivore and like
or even with other issues i like
listening to what other people you know
opposing sides assuming they're both you
know intelligent interesting sources
especially when they're
i love it when they're sort of really
testing that diet meaning they're
athletes or in some way really testing
it not just like vaguely saying what's
healthy or not for you
but like really what is life like under
this particular diet yeah and i think
that probably
everybody's different and so in the same
way that some people tolerate like some
people
can't tolerate nightshades or some
people can't tolerate certain spices or
some people can't tolerate gluten or
some people thrive off of this or that
and
i've heard it said and discussed that
there's a great deal to sort of what
your body's used to what your ancestors
ate where you where
because it seems like the human body is
pretty adaptable so
you can adapt to eating a certain type
of a
food
and
so that if you're you know if your
family comes from a certain part of the
world where certain things aren't grown
or or more meat is eaten or
because there's people who are vegan
their entire lives and they're
incredibly healthy and they thrive and
there's athletes and there's people like
rich roll who i like who's
vegan and an athlete but it might be
something where that's
that's working really well for him but
it wouldn't work well for somebody else
and i think there's also an element of
people who try these things
and then feel really good
or feel really bad and they make a
conclusion based on that initial
period of time when it might be
something where it makes you feel really
good temporarily
but then over time you're going to be
depleted of certain things
and then we also live in a world where
like our soil is depleted and
there's a lot of processing that takes
out of foods a lot of things that we
need so
i just think that there's no
kind of one right answer you can look at
it from just a health perspective and
then you can also look at it from like a
morality and ethics perspective and then
also like what's the impact on the
environment and all those things are
important and i think that i've watched
a lot of films and things and
for a while right after that i might
think oh my god i can't believe i ate
this thing last week and now i'm going
to go back to being 100 vegan because i
just watched this thing and it's fresh
in my mind and now i'm thinking about it
in a certain way but then over time that
sort of
fades
and then you start to get a bit more
loose
and
for me
i
i will end up eating a lot of things
that
aren't vegan
usually in the context where i'm not
adding to the consumption of it so
um
like at rikers there was most of the
meat there was kind of weird and fake
but there was like a chicken
every
thursday and sunday there was um it was
actual chicken like the leg was that the
most exciting thing for people
oh yeah oh and then the most fights
broke out on chicken day because it was
like heightened thursday and sunday said
yeah chicken day so
that was the the most uh real meat
you're getting is the chicken yeah a lot
of compressed or duck duck white white
or dark meat dark is the the leg in the
thigh
and it was cooked surprisingly well
and so i would always eat it i don't
know i mean yeah it's there and
it's not
from a health perspective one could say
well that's probably the shittiest of
the shitty chickens that are full of
antibiotics and hormones and terrible
things and
so it's not optimal from that point of
view
um
but
it's like if it's otherwise going to be
thrown in the trash then
yeah you're not adding to it right or
you know like i've been drunk at a party
and
eaten a bunch of stuff that one would
think i would never eat yeah but it's
not like i ran to the store and bought
it or went to a restaurant or same
liquor makes me eat things i shouldn't
be eating
oh yeah or or maybe should
well my life is caught as you wrote me
in the email life is complicated and
fascinating and and so was our decisions
when we're drunk
i actually am a big fan of 7-eleven
i go there sometimes late at night to
think about life and i'll eat
i'll eat whatever the stuff they have i
also think it's fascinating how our
bodies intuitively know
what if you're like quiet enough
and you think about like what you're
craving yeah as long as it's not like
if you're craving like some processed
junky food that's probably something
that's not quite functional but if
you're crazy like sometimes i'll i'll
i'll be like
i must have avocado or like i'll want to
eat an entire parsley salad and then
it's happened i went through a phase
where
um
and here i'm like do i say this out loud
i went through a phase of are you gonna
say it where i was i know now i have to
say it
um
where
i couldn't get enough
um i don't know where it started like
whose house i was at or whatever but
grass-fed butter i just i was like i
could tell that my body wanted whatever
was there yeah and so
i suppose i could have investigated it
and thought like well what's in there is
it like vitamin k vitamin d what is it
in the grass fed butter because it
wasn't regular but like regular butter
ew no but like this grass-fed butter
like i felt like i just wanted i needed
it so there's probably something in
there and maybe i could have gone and
just taken a lot of vitamin k and then
not eaten the butter but
um but there is something in there
that's fascinating i had that last night
actually with um
i went to grocer grocery store and i had
i had a craving for tomatoes
i was like what the hell is this
like what i don't know right so i think
it's weird you should listen to that and
then just get a bunch of tomatoes
because it's probably something in there
it was like
it felt right when i was little my
mother no but that that's exactly what i
was saying is that somehow your body
knows without you knowing and today i
have zero interest in tomatoes yeah did
you eat the tomatoes though yeah okay
well then you probably i ate way too
many but that's all right
or maybe not enough
there you go see what you were saying
anyway i think these things like shift
and change and there's not like a right
answer and then there's something where
it's like one person might do well on
something another person doesn't or you
might do well on something for like i
might you know maybe if i ate a bunch of
liver i'd feel better because i'm
getting
vitamins that i don't that i that i'm
lacking
but then once i get them i'm fine and i
don't need that anymore and i could
potentially get those from other sources
or
um
but yeah when i was little i used to
crave my mother said i craved um not
craved but she said i would always eat
sardines but i wouldn't eat the pieces i
would only eat the whole ones which have
the bones in them and i used to chew on
chicken bones and try to eat eggshells
when i was like a top like little so i
think all of those things have um
calcium and other minerals and commons
there's probably something there that i
needed because you'd think as a little
kid i wouldn't be drawn to oily fish
and bones and eggshells yeah it's
interesting because like you're saying
the explanation for the craving is
probably the nutrients you're getting
but when you're imagining the craving
you're not obviously imagining the
nutrients you're imagining the texture
the taste
the feel the i mean a lot of the things
that we actually experience as we're
eating that's our brain probably
tricking us right but do you love
tomatoes
well um
i think we determined that love is
impossible to define
so
are you extremely fond of do you think
tomatoes are like one of the most
delicious foods no no but maybe but yet
you crave them maybe it's generational
because it's a big russian thing with
potatoes and tomatoes and
because it's good with vodka right
salted
uh we were talking about the menu and
the early days of the restaurant
in new york so what was on the menu what
was what kind of foods were you playing
with
do you remember
um
was that one of the challenging things
is putting together because you're
you're like crafting a new thing
in new york where it's extremely
competitive but over time it got easier
and easier and then also i had you know
it was i wasn't coming up with new
dishes it was the people that work there
so i feel like if i could take credit
for something it would be recognizing
talent
and
um
you know and when dishes were developed
this is when i was there on my own so i
it was opened with matthew and jeffrey
and then um within a year matthew was
out
um and jeffrey was still involved as
like the you know the corporate sort of
side of it but then over time
um i separated from that infrastructure
as well and then was completely on my
own
and part i did that because i was
growing one lucky duck on the side and
that was growing and growing and growing
and i knew there was something there
and yet the two businesses were
completely intertwined and so um
potential investors would come at me and
they would see this very messy situation
where i owned one lucky duck and jeffrey
chatter owned the restaurant and how do
we move forward from there and then
people would say i should shut down the
restaurant and just focus on one lucky
duck and i wanted them all to be
together under one umbrella and to move
forward where everybody's incentives
were aligned and
what was the magic why was it so
successful so quickly would you say
i want to half jokingly but not joking
but sort of say that it was about the
the love and the food and the space
uh can you define love but
it's it's there was something special so
i always when people ask me about
opening a restaurant i say i don't want
to get back into the restaurant business
unless it's the same restaurant in the
same space
because there was something about that
space
that felt
um
i guess felt magical for lack of a
better word and
the energy of a lot of the people there
and
i think that people really cared about
it and so
for whatever reason it just there was an
energy about the place would you ever do
it again yes you ever consider it
uh
that's a tough thing in new york but
you're thinking
okay well it's there it's there
let me ask you this question
because i've been searching for that
myself like asking myself this question
if i you know the last meal question
like what's
the best meal you've ever eaten in your
life like if you had if i had to murder
you at the end of this and you get one
meal but you can travel anywhere in the
world
um what would you what would you eat
it's one of those questions where i feel
like it i should have an answer prepared
no it's too it's too difficult to sort
of pick favorites
but
if somebody would you know force you to
choose
i was eating something once and i had
the thought
that if i was going to die
this i would come here and order plate
after plate of this and eat this do you
remember what it was yes some diner in
the middle of nowhere no it was um pure
food and wine was on irving place and
then
and then the the kitchen connected to
the one lucky duck juice bar which had
an entrance on 17th street so it's kind
of like this l shape and then there was
a huge garden in the back on the corner
was casimono and barhamon
which was mario batali and joe
bastianich
were behind that and it was very focused
on
meat but also like organ meats and
strange unusual finished restaurant wow
lots of good reviews yeah it was really
good
um
this is just a funny that we surrounded
it but barhamon was um
was it this tiny little bar
and i went in there once with tobin
late
and
i don't know why we ended up going there
but it was right before they closed
and drank red wine and they had tomato
bread
and it's just
like a
baguette although it's a spanish
whatever it's like a bread like a
baguette like a thin
that they toast and i think they rub it
with garlic and they don't even put
tomato slices on it it's like they
rub it and the tomato juices all over it
it was just bread and tomato juice and
probably some garlic flavor and really
good salt
and with some wine and red wine and we
sat there and ordered a plate ate it
ordered another one ate it or another
one i think we had like six plates and i
remember sitting there thinking
i could just eat this until my stomach
bursts and then and so if this is like
if somebody was like
what's the last
i would just want to sit there and eat
plate after plate i think if you went
back there and ate the same thing it
wouldn't taste nearly as good like was
there something magical about that night
about
the way that bread was made in that
night
the way you felt at that night the wine
the
something or do you think
like where's the power from that food
come from is it the food itself
or is it the environment
i'm sure it's both but
like if somebody brought a plate of it
here right now it would be completely
delicious
yeah but it might not feel as kind of
that it felt magical but it was the
whole
warmth of the experience and
and the red wine and see how i'm doing
in texas right now so it's different and
if i keep forgetting and thinking it's
late at night
yeah we're surrounded by
this is this whole place is
anti-huberman there's no light
uh well it's it's pro-huberman if it's
in the afternoon or the evening
except for these bright lights
if they were lower down
if they were like down below then
they're hitting the tops of our eyes but
it's the light coming from above that's
destructive at night because it's
hitting the bottom of your eyes so it's
like mimicking the sun
which is signaling your body that it's
time to be awake
so
as much as possible so i do this in the
evenings i shut off all the overhead
lights i try to dim the lights as much
as i can and and i turn on like a lamp
versus an overhead light
are you also doing the caffeine thing
like not
not consuming much caffeine way before
bed
oh i can't yeah i usually
don't have caffeine
late i try not to have it so
ideally i would drink into the night
cafe 2 pm would be my last i wouldn't
ideally i wouldn't drink coffee after
two but plenty of times i do
especially if i haven't had midday
coffee then i worry i'm gonna get a
headache that makes you way more
responsible than me let me return to
love
what do you think makes for a good
romantic relationship
given your experience
i mean this question i think a mutual
respect is a big part of it
mutual respect
that's interesting well and
understanding it in a way that you want
what's best for the other person not in
a way that you would sacrifice yourself
for them necessarily
but
in a very healthy way
so i think a healthy relationship is
where you know you want what's best for
the other person so i always find it
tragic
um
like say
you started dating somebody who then
would get jealous or upset if you spent
too much time working on something
right and but but that's like your life
so if you're working on
some robotics thing and you're having
some breakthrough and so you just want
to spend a lot of time
wherever you spend a lot of time doing
those things and then that other person
got all bent out of shape and it became
like a competition that to me seems very
unhealthy because if somebody
if it was
if it was like a genuine
healthy love
she would want you to
be doing those things
yeah that's a good observation but
to me i think the way to achieve that
is actually or the easiest way to
achieve at least for me is actually
legitimately be excited by
the things the other person is excited
by
so like
not in some generic sense it's good for
them to be doing the robotics thing
like it's more like
you become a fan of all the cool things
that they're doing in their life so like
i i definitely have this i somebody told
me recently there's a term for this but
i love
like
watching other people
like um succeed
be excited about [ __ ]
like i like celebrating other people
like it's fun for me to watch people do
the thing they love doing so like i you
know in some sense
that's reinvigorating to me and exciting
to me and so
one of the things for me in a
relationship is like
you get excited by watching another
person do the thing they're excited
about it's not like i intellectually
know it's good for them to have their
own thing and they you know
it's like i legit get excited by
their own thing because otherwise that's
what i mean it's like
that person would be excited because
you're excited yeah and but they would i
think the easiest way to achieve that is
actually be like
what am i trying to it's like it's not
like saying that you should be
excited it's like you i can't help
yourself but be excited that's why right
but i think that's possible but
it's possible for that to be the case
for somebody that
like
might have an appreciation for what
you're doing but isn't like that's not
what that person's gonna go spend their
time
on them yeah they were by themselves
yeah right so they might the other
person might you know
be really good at a musical instrument
that requires a lot of practice and
you're not interested in playing that
musical instrument but you appreciate
the beauty of the music and understand
that that person is getting something
out of it so you would be excited when
they get a chance to practice or or
whatnot you know so it's
that kind of a do you think
loves should be simple or complicated
in a relationship
well it might be inherently complicated
i think i i may have asked huberman the
exact same question
forget what he said
i thought it was interesting when you
asked elon about love
oh boy yeah he that that's a
that's that's that's gonna be
conversation number like seven that he
actually answers it
well what was interesting
that i found admirable was this sort of
like a duty to humanity
i think you asked about it not in a
about person but about the work
and so it was like it was like a to do
to put all this
energy to try to kind of like move
things forward knowing that he will
probably die before it gets there you're
talking about like a something related
to the science of
rocketry
yeah
right he's kind of a rocket scientist
but whatever
you were asking him about whether
something could be accomplished and he
said yes but not in his lifetime but
he's going to keep pushing it forward
anyway so i felt like that was a really
you know
to put so much of yourself into
something just to kind of move the baton
forward for humanity it was a
struck me as an admirable
thing you know where there's no
great reward in in terms of
you're gonna
you know you're gonna see that invention
happen or you're gonna see mars
colonized or whatever it is
but you'll you'll you're willing to put
in all the work and brainpower to try to
push it along
like thinking about the biggest possible
impact on the world
just thinking about humanity i think all
of us when we do cool things are
contributing to humanity and it's it's
good to think of it that way when you
run a restaurant and you make all the
people happy
i don't know that's part of that it's
good to think
big like that and elon does definitely
but when i asked them about love
i'm you know just knowing him personally
now
i'm asking about
the personal question about love but i'm
giving him the freedom to escape it
which he he always does that's very
generous
because i don't want to trap him i i
understand it's it's a difficult
so you know he's better at solving
engineering problems than talking about
love
uh the other thing he's really good at
is um going to the joke so for him
um
you know
for him love and all those kinds of
things especially those kind of cliche
sounding things
are
are are the stuff of memes it's the
stuff
the easiest way you can talk about it is
humor the same with trauma like personal
trauma easiest stuff for him to talk
about is the it's taken
his laugh about it he has he's been very
tough uh privately or on podcast to talk
about personal like
difficult stuff and for me obviously
that's often the most interesting stuff
as humans like
where's your darkness
you know but
uh for him it's tough for a lot of
people it's tough but it's important to
go there
maybe maybe first in the privacy of your
own mind
and i think you know bringing it back to
the relationship thing is wanting to um
like understand and accept
those things about somebody else i mean
sort of cliche to say that you can't
change somebody
um
and you don't want to also like try to
change yourself for somebody but you can
sort of figure things out and be willing
to
make adjustments and
navigate for the sake of something
working
and sometimes that comes from
understanding and which
might require a lot of effort
and yeah open-mindedness if somebody's
kind of very different from you
yeah and being uh being fragile yourself
revealing your flaws and getting to
learn about theirs and getting to see
the beauty in them
because that's the good stuff
or if if if the flaws are too much of a
red flag then you walk away that's the
hard stuff you either the red flags
might be the thing that you actually get
to love deeply because they're a flawed
human or it might be the reason to walk
away quickly
and you don't know
it's it's although if it's like if it's
a if it's a red flag then it by
definition is something that's telling
you to walk away if it was just like
something about their character that's
challenging
you could appreciate that
or understand it
but it's not something that like they're
intentionally trying to use to deceive
you i think red flags it's like
i guess it's more about like
manipulation and or like somebody's kind
of extreme dysfunction or something
would be red flags but i think there
could be things that
are
quirky or weird or
even dark about somebody
um that are acceptable yeah but they
might look like red flags if if there's
a
if there's someone crying on on the
subway that's a red flag for me that she
might be like an emotional basketball
yeah this is a high maintenance crazy
person yeah yeah
that's true but you know it could also
be there could be a deeper story to it
so that's what i'm trying to tell you
that's true
all right
what advice would you give
to young folks today if they want to
launch a restaurant in new york city
and then message somebody on twitter
i was before you finished the sentence i
was about to say read a lot of books
but then you then because you said what
advice would you give to young people
today and i was like read a lot of books
yeah and then you got to the restaurant
part yeah
oh no i mean that's i was joking about
the restaurant i said yeah about life i
would say uh not just about a
career as a restaurateur
but
just in life how to be successful how to
be
how to live a life that can be
fulfilling and how to live a life they
can be proud of
i read a lot of books it's complicated
because have you figured it out yet no
but
i think self-awareness is key but i also
think
there's some of those things where like
people kind of have to learn their own
lessons
but
i think in part because i never had kids
and i never wanted kids i feel like
through my book i keep thinking that i
want a lot of the lessons that i learned
to be
useful to other people particularly
younger people
and in many cases younger females
to maybe understand themselves a little
better along the way because i think
that you know a lot of mistakes that i
made and things that happened
or things that i did that i'm
embarrassed about
um
or things that i stepped into that i
wouldn't have otherwise stepped into or
allowed to happen
were a result of
in many cases
like
insecurity
um like a lack of confidence
and um and i think in the context of
moving forward with
relationships
being really careful to understand why
you're there or if you're repeating a
pattern that's something that
is sort of cliche but i feel like it's
very i mean art cliche
cliches are things that are true they're
just repeated a lot but they're
but anyway
the idea that people repeat patterns
right yes so
i think that's very true
right
and so to be aware of that and to figure
it out sooner rather than later so you
don't keep stepping into the same
thing over and over again you mentioned
sort of giving yourself
time and space to think
yeah which sometimes isn't possible but
don't let momentum of life sort of carry
you away right and i think for me one of
the things that would have scared me
about having kids is the chaos of it
um or not being able to handle it but i
think that's like that's just me not
most people
you ran a restaurant i know
which is probably why i would go home at
night and lie on the floor and cry
or how often do you do that
um what's
do you like a good cry
i do
music usually or
what can we can you paint the scene what
and just in general yeah is there
candles i cried this morning okay not
intentionally not fabulous or just
overwhelmed
it was like a
you know i looked a little bit at
instagram
and saw
what was it
very often they're like
like these little animal rescue stories
or whatever but this is a this guy matt
who used to be my trainer years ago
and put this little montage video to
music that was interesting if there
hadn't been music i probably wouldn't
have cried but it was um showing his
wife
having their second child not
not showing it but like the sort of
before and then you know the baby in her
arms right afterwards and then bringing
the baby home it was this very short
little clip
but set to music yeah and i watched that
and started to cry
but like it's not i didn't sob or
anything so
i think i cry easily um
interestingly
though
in actual
horrifically tragic things
or when they apply to me i might not cry
and then people find that unusual and
that was in the film that
i was my sister my father described that
when my parents got divorced i didn't i
didn't cry and i just whereas my sister
bawled her eyes out and i i didn't cry
at all ever and i just
didn't say anything i want to talk about
it um
and um
you know like when i was sentenced to
jail i didn't cry
um
so a lot of times when something really
big happens i get a little bit weirdly
um
i don't know but i
very often too much to feel it all
directly so you kind of cry it out later
slowly
right maybe years later maybe years
later yeah maybe that's what i'm really
crying about when i cry at these little
videos or something yeah i don't know
but i'm glad for it because i feel like
it always feels like kind of a relief
well let me ask this because it's
interesting what you would say
do you have regrets
about
things in your life
like what do you regret if there's a one
day you could live
again
or which day would you pick
like relive and make different choices
um well
like one obvious thing could be the day
that i let anthony strange is in the
door if i'd instead you know if at any
time early on i instead just pushed him
out you know that my life would be
wildly different
um
it's hard to
so that's the biggest mistake of your
life i would say just
letting
anthony to your life i think yes i think
one could argue that's the biggest
mistake but then at the same time you
never know because
like
when i um
i was in a sort of a dark relationship
that then led to
the restaurant am i having the one lucky
duck brand
so i felt like
that darkness
it's like if you married a horribly
abusive person but you had a beautiful
child and then you go on and you have
this beautiful child and you think well
if i hadn't been with that horribly
abusive person i wouldn't have this
beautiful child so i wouldn't go undo it
so i feel like a lot of things are like
that
and i guess i could optimistically hope
that
there are good things down the road
where i'll think well i'm here and i'm
appreciate i'm grateful for it and
therefore i'm grateful for the things
that got me here which include a lot of
dark things
it's hard to say because a lot of people
were hurt in my case but i
am optimistic that i can make those
things up and
there also hurts that were
um i mean in some cases emotionally but
also
very much financial and i feel like
those are
numbers and the
um employees were all paid back so
anybody else that
is out money because of everything that
happened
isn't somebody that's like not able to
um
you know
feed themselves everybody most of those
people have plenty of money and it's
like not a big deal but i still want to
repay all of it
um
and it's numbers it's not
um
you know like nobody died and
sometimes when i think about my own
challenges
um they feel sort of inconsequential in
comparison to other things going on in
the world
so
um
you know like
yes it's hard being humiliated or it's
hard to have people say nasty things
about you on
twitter instagram but really who cares
because that's just words and things and
i'm not like fleeing my home and
watching people get
shot so and they're still
out of this darkness are
out of this you can still that you still
have a lot of time to create something
beautiful in the world
yeah maybe something even more beautiful
than you've ever done before i am
optimistic and i also feel like
you know part of the reason i like
having these conversations because i
feel like people
will
learn stuff from my
shitty experiences to avoid
going through their own shitty
experience and i've heard
a ton of that from
a lot of women and some men um
you know writing to me saying that they
went through something similar and
nobody understood and
you know my story help them or
um
you know might help them get somebody
else out of a situation
so making it useful feels good
so through all of this
leon was with you
he uh recently had a birthday
march i guess yes 12. yeah i made him a
phenomenal
meat cake or a a layered
cake that involved
a variety of animal foods he's not a
vegetarian no he's not okay but i also
give him like really high quality stuff
but yeah he's not a vegan a vegetarian
let me ask you a hard question
do you think about the tragic fact that
dogs live much shorter
lives than us humans
do you think about
his mortality
all the time i kind of try not to but
all the time because he told me
in traveling here
to austin texas
you're
not in the habit of leaving leon
by himself
uh well he's not by himself but i no i
haven't been away from him
in
certainly since before
covid
um
so i'm not used to it and so
i people always say that dogs have um
like that dogs have attachment issues or
get separation anxiety but
in my case at least it's like i think
he's fine i'm the one that
is you know he's like fine i'm the one
that gets anxious about it
um being away from him
you're the one who acts like a dog when
you say you come back and you're super
excited to see him yeah i can have
people
be on the floor and wiggle your tail and
drool and all that kind of stuff but do
you think about the fact you know that
you might lose leon soon
i do i think about it all i mean i i try
not to think about it but i'm scared and
i um yeah it's scary but then i also
just try to understand that it's
inevitable and um
i mean
yeah
assuming i'm still around
then um
that's i think one of the things about
having adopting a dog or getting or
caring for an animal unless it's one of
those animals that lives a really long
time i just found out that parrots live
an extraordinarily long time
um but they're annoying
so you get it's a trade-off
the ones we love live a short time the
ones that enjoy
right live a long time so i just think
it's one of those things
that
you just know what's gonna happen and
it's just part of life and i think it's
one of those
pains that's
it's painful but you just kind of have
to go through it um
and what's the alternative you're not
gonna
it's like saying you would never want to
fall in love because of the heartbreak
that's gonna inevitably come yeah so
some people do that they just avoid
exactly ever you're saying screw it i'm
diving right in yes it was all worth it
what about your own mortality you think
about yourself dying less so than i was
before
um
i think i i wrote about that and i put
this letter dear mr fox online which i
never intended to do but i did because
of all the
misconceptions about the film and our in
our relationship and so i put this thing
up online that i'd written
on my phone
on multiple subway rides
and at the end of it i talk about
because especially then when like it was
the height of everything was gone
and you know what do i have to live for
i sort of
noticed and wrote about how differently
i felt about things whereas i used to be
afraid
i used to have like a healthy fear of
you know being pushed in front of a
train because that happens you know in
new york or anywhere or
you know i had a healthy fear of
like i don't know walking down a dark
street at night but
i noticed that at the time
i didn't really have those fears because
i was like yeah what do i like what do i
have to lose like who cares you know i'm
i don't have anything anymore what i
have to lose so
i certainly feel much less that way
but something about those feelings
lingered where i'm less afraid of it
or more just
less afraid of it but hoping it's not
some sort of a gruesome way
i mean some people are really afraid of
flying and i feel like well
statistically it's extremely safe and if
it's going to happen it's going to
happen there's nothing you can do
like there's really nothing you can do
unless you're gonna like
do what that guy and that small plane
did the other day and like leap over and
was able to take control of the plane
but i mean like a commercial flight
so it's like if you're gonna die you're
gonna die and it's just your time and
all you can do is hope that
i would i would probably prefer to have
as little awareness about it as possible
you know it's like if you'd rather have
somebody
if you're gonna get shot you'd rather
have somebody shoot you in the back of
the head and you didn't see it coming
and just boom lights out versus
somebody holding a gun to your head and
then you're gonna feel all this fear
um and have to like feel all of that
which also made me think of
um
you know animals and animals suffering
in the way that some people
argue that
because of the conditions and the fear
that that's like
that's like in their bodies when they're
killed which is an interesting thing to
think about
um
yeah i clearly struggle with the ethics
of
i just
i think about it a lot
about
um
you know like our current food system
which involves
uh a system that everybody has sort of
accepted and normalized where
um
like say aliens did come down
yeah and
looked at us
and realized that were a particularly
good source of whatever fuel they need
so then they
imprisoned us all
in
cages that were like the equivalent of
like sardines and jammed in an elevator
and then
we were bred
and
we would get sick and we'd go crazy and
we'd do the equivalent of like pecking
and then we'd get abused and then
like grotesquely and brutally killed and
that was like our entire lives and so
if like aliens came down and
started and did all of that
we would have to be okay with that
which is something that
my um
was said to me after watching this movie
called our daily bread many years ago
um but it's an interesting way to think
about it because
i mean we would have to be okay with it
because that's kind of what we're doing
now
right yeah we've normalized certain
kinds of cruelty and i don't people
think yeah people think that like i
would object to
hunting
uh hunting for sport i think is
grotesque
but if you're
hunting and then
you're gonna eat the entire animal
and you're hunting in a way where it's
kind of like
you know that that animal like lived a
free and happy life until that moment in
the same way that the animal lived a
free and happy moment
lived a free and happy
life or we don't know maybe they were
depressed but
they lived a free life until
like the lion came and took it down
so
is a human
shooting an animal for food somehow more
tragic or horrible than a lion attacking
an elk
yeah well so
there's a lot of complexities to it on
top of all of that so one you said
so hunting for sport is bad but there's
this like complex ethical equation of
the fact that hunting for sport is the
thing that often funds the preservation
of a species
that's well no that's another
complicated layer there's like the um
maui venison
all the deer in hawaii
and um
i might have gotten maui venison treats
for leon
um but they're
they're hunting those deer
is a way of preserving
the yeah so i mean these things are
complicated but that's why i don't have
a problem with
somebody
shooting an elk or bringing it home and
eating it like my
um you know like i've eaten elk jerky
and things like that from that's one of
those situations where like i wouldn't
morally have a problem with it and for
me it's also i'm not one of those people
where i think
like you i wouldn't eat meat it's more
like i don't want to add to the
consumption of it and i wouldn't want to
eat sort of like the factory farmed
meat
necessarily unless i'm in prison and
it's otherwise going to get thrown away
but
uh hashtag uh a lot of a lot of things
you know
you know you make
do things differently there but yeah um
so you know it's just these things are
complicated but
so it's not about like you i don't want
that in my body it's sort of like what
where did it come from and and what's
going on here and
um
i think that
like if you just followed joe rogan's
instagram
there's sort of a bit of a glorification
of meat that
because i listened to enough that i
heard the one where he talked there was
a recent one where he's talking about
anthony bourdain and in that
conversation i think it was that one he
explained that
he sort of did it in summary so i feel
like he talked about it in the past but
did all this research
and came to the conclusion
based on all his research came to the
conclusion that he was either going to
be vegetarian or
shoot his own
meat yeah and hunt and so
that that's totally different that's
something i mean that's very like
admirable
i think and he has the means to do it
but but if you not only that but he does
it with a bow
right even more so so it is a good
question it's
it's a good question how we uh
get out of this factory right
because i do like i i like i like meat i
think it's delicious i i we're dependent
on the not just
uh on the
the nutrients and the taste we're also
dependent on the cost
a lot of people have gotten used to a
particular kind of cost that they pay
for
meat
right but i think if we wiped out all
the
government subsidies it would be a
completely different story because why
why are vegetables so expensive
and
subsidizing some tomatoes yesterday i'm
i'm protesting why is salad so expensive
right but none of the the if you
if you look at the subsidies that are
given to
um the all of the inputs to the meat
industry like the grain and soy and
whatnot
and then to the meat and dairy
industries and all the subsidies that
prop up those industries and allow those
products to be cheap and and
sustainable from a business perspective
not environmental
it's government subsidies so what if we
took all that away
and then also what if we gave that to
um you know the the kale and hemp and
fresh greens
farmers
then and made those foods more
affordable
and then had meat reflect its actual
true cost
then you know then people would just eat
more vegetables and less meat because of
the cost
you mentioned that you crossed off one
item from your list i forget what the
item was but
um oh it was
i had previously thought that i would
want to go to vegas one day just to
cross that off my list it's not like
i was like ooh one day i want to go to
vegas it was just like i imagined i
would only go there once just to see it
and then
be done with it
yeah
yeah
that's a good one that's a good one and
i i still think you can do it because
there's a particular vegas experience
that's worth having and there's maybe a
couple of vegas experiences that are
worth having i find casinos horribly
depressing
because i think they're just predatory
everything about them is predatory not
it's not it's not the casinos that are
important it's the people culture and
the whole the people crazy the people
you meet the people you meet in the
chaos that is las vegas can create
a memorable experience
you lose track of what is
what is day what is night
you can get drunk and make all the
mistakes
that somehow create a beautiful
masterpiece at the end of it
that's for another time what else is on
the bucket list what items on the bucket
list you haven't done yet
you really really would like we talked
about mortality
that that there's a finite deadline
what pops in your head is something that
you want us to do
what i want is to not die and owe people
money
so so whatever mistakes you make i wanna
i wanna live to write those things and i
also felt really strongly about
my
what i'd
what i and everybody in the business had
built
and
um
so
a big part of me wants to
um
resurrect the brand
because when i i felt really strongly
about it like i had that feeling that
this was
this was going to be a thing that i i
wanted to build and grow and could have
a really positive impact and outlast me
and um would you bring it back as the
same name
yeah well i i put the logo on my arm
that's kind of how strongly i felt about
it and so
when i did that and around that time and
all of that time i felt
really really strongly that um
quietly
because it feels like
a little bit bold
but quietly felt
really almost with a certainty that it
was going to be something really big and
it was growing and growing
and all signs were pointing towards
there i was just sort of stalled and
couldn't figure out the logistics
and then enter mr fox
so the universe can be quite
absurdly cruel at times
but yeah
but that that is something uh
that's something worth reaching for is
repay the debts of the past
and then people have said to me that
leon achieved some kind of immortality
via
being in the documentary
and then i might i don't understand this
world at all but i might do like an nft
thing
related to leon's image which would be
another way of
kind of immortalizing his image at least
yeah
but that's a um
i mean it's a
potentially in progress
kind of a crazy leap but and potentially
relaunching the restaurant
possibly yes
there's a restaurant and there's one
lucky duck in that brand and they're
sort of
separate but related
um and
they could each exist independently i
liked it better when they
existed together because i felt like
they were very complementary in a lot of
ways and they made sense together but
either one could be done separately
without the other
do you think you will find love again
given
the chaos yet to go through
um
i have and i never talk about it i've
never
talked about it you have fallen love
again
yes
but also in a kind of
possibly doomed temporary way
which
you don't like it simple do you
it's not that it's not simple it's
actually quite simple it's just that
again there's a large age gap
i am the older one
which in itself isn't a problem because
again i wouldn't
i wouldn't want to
like if somebody wanted kids and a
family i wouldn't want to hold them back
from that and
so if i sort of wanted to be with
somebody who wanted those things
i
even if i was completely in love with
somebody i would have to kind of like
you know
hurt
endure the pain to be like no i'm gonna
keep you from those things so you should
go do those things so that's that's the
source of
the temporariness
no
it's a bit related to
like logistics and
living one place and having it like
extremely different lifestyles is this a
prince of some sort
no
does he have a castle
um
no okay all right no no you're gonna say
who it is or we're gonna keep that a
mystery
i don't on the one hand like i feel like
it's a
it's protective for me to talk about it
in some ways
but
i also worry because
very often i avoid
saying anything because for a lot of
reasons but
one being that people freak out and just
assume that i'm gonna step into
something horrible again because i did
step into something
horribly destructive again after mr fox
and
what happened was i allowed something to
happen and so
going back to that what advice would you
give to people i would
i would tell people to be very careful
to be deliberate about
who they're getting involved with
and thoughtful about it and making sure
that they're not just allowing something
to happen so it's like
you know
men
can sometimes be and i suppose women can
be as well but people can be very
persistent
sometimes that's a good thing but it
could also be a dangerous thing because
sometimes somebody might just and this
has happened to me a lot where somebody
just wears you down and you're like ugh
fine you know
um
that's funny and yeah yeah no i mean but
it works it's shockingly like the things
that i've done in the spirit of like or
not wanting to hurt somebody's feelings
that's another that's another dangerous
be nice let's get married just to be
nice that's another dangerous thing and
also maybe he's just i feel like i'm
like circling back to all these
unanswered questions from before but
um i didn't marry i married
i married him he like convinced me to
marry him
in this very quick annoying way and as
if it was like something i had to do and
i'd be protected and all kinds of weird
reasons and it was just
like my response to my my agreeing to
marry him was like ugh
fine yeah and and then i remember being
embarrassed at city hall
going to get the license
you know people who are in love and
wanting to get married aren't sitting in
city hall mortified and embarrassed you
know so yeah but so it was so i sort of
cringe when people call him my
ex-husband because i don't think of him
that way it's sort of
is even though
technically that's correct yeah but
there's a there's a powerful romantic
notion to the thing and do those words
and that that had nothing to do with you
getting married it was more
it was just like another thing that he
made me do like a chore that just had
you know unfortunate consequences of
like
then having to get divorced in the whole
yeah i think i think even weddings are
romantic like um the whole the cheesy
thing there's
you know
yeah they are those are cool uh i agree
we don't get many many of those in life
um well you know what let's keep it a
mystery
let's keep the person a mystery
uh to be continued
season two
conversations with some like a known
person or anything but i feel like
people always worry that
i'm stepping back into something and i
don't have the energy to be certain
should they be defensive and no there
you go don't worry friends no and also
just
remember that thing i was saying about
how like it's good if you get to know
somebody really slowly over a long
period of time yeah it's kind of one of
those situations
so i feel very confident that i'm like
certain it's i'm not stepping into
something where i'm gonna be surprised
and somebody turns out to be not who
they presented themselves to be so it's
that wise way to do it
especially for
me yeah and also again it's like i would
i would i would caution people to be
careful about
um
you know wanting to go into something
deliberately versus
kind of getting caught up in something
and or rushed or that said
i would i would suggest people take that
cautionary advice but uh you know
sometimes you just fall in love
yeah love at first sight is a thing
there are those stories of
you know sweet stories of older people
that i don't know
you can get hurt for it too but
don't don't
listen to your heart
this was an incredible conversation
uh
we talked for way over four hours we did
yeah
and uh
yeah i feel like i can keep talking to
you this was amazing uh summer thank you
so much for being honest for
for
being fearless in answering all the
questions
all the difficult questions
and thank you for trying to create
something special with your restaurant
and
maybe create something special still in
your future
yeah i hope so thank you for
having me i kept thinking um
i kept thinking that like i was gonna
get a message that was like just kidding
i just i've listened to your podcast a
lot and so i've
certainly felt very intimidated knowing
who's
sat if not in this actual chair in this
chair in another location or maybe here
very are you nervous
yes
and um
yeah i was nervous too yeah but at the
same but also because i've because i
know the way that you speak in your
style i felt like it was gonna feel like
a good natural conversation as opposed
to sometimes you have conversations
where it's like
anyway
so i didn't feel nervous because of like
what i was walking into i felt nervous
that i was gonna you know sound stupid
and boring and everybody would be like
why did he interview her like it was
exciting you happy with it how do we do
yeah i think so
very often after are you self-critical
after stuff
yes when you go home tonight are you
gonna be like
happy with yourself or not
i mean i feel good i don't feel like i
can't think of anything that i said that
i regret maybe there's things that you
know somebody's gonna yell at me because
i said something that i said like meat
is good or something or i don't you know
i guess
like vegan judgment yes
um yes but i think it's more useful to
be honest about the contradictions and
conflicting feelings because i feel like
that's what most people have and so if
you want to help people
shift a certain way yeah you were raw
honest
it was beautiful it was beautiful to
watch
thank you for the books
your darkness today was visible
but the beauty too it was it was an
amazing conversation um
i'm i'm really really happy with it i'm
honored that you sit down with me that
was awesome
i'm
floored that you're honored and i'm
honored that you asked me to be here so
thank you sarah
thanks for listening to this
conversation with sarma melangalis to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from playwright august wilson
confront the dark parts of yourself
and work to banish them with
illumination and forgiveness
your willingness to wrestle with your
demons will cause your angels to sing
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time